this is jaco podcast number 94 with echo
Charles and me Jacques are willing
good evening echo good evening the black
cloud of smoke exploded silently outside
the open door of the dakota obscuring
for the moment my view of the
geometrical Dutch landscape deserted but
for a few forlorn cows as soon as the
sea it appeared below us I started to
think about the flack and I knew that
everyone else in the aircraft must be
worrying as well when we crossed the
east anglican coast line that slight
wave of movement had flickered down the
aircraft as the men checked their
watches calculating the time it would
take to fly over the sea and come within
range of the now alerted German
anti-aircraft guns below us the air sea
rescue launches of the RAF dotting the
water at precise intervals were
pleasantly comforting the narrow band of
beach which was the coast of Holland had
aroused us once again as the flooded
fields flashed into view
private Harrison had leaned across to
point out the guns on the ground
shooting up at the massed ranks of our
aircraft at the sound of my Batman's
voice which had been silent for the past
hour
the men near to the dood open doorway
had craned forward to see what they
could while the rest anxious for the
first indications of the enemy had
twisted their necks to peer through the
small windows at their backs at first I
could see nothing and I was stupidly
aggravated that everyone but myself
could spot gun flashes then came that
cloud of smoke producing an odd sense of
satisfaction a reaction which
immediately shamed me this is the
behavior of a small boy for all that it
was satisfying not to feel scared by it
perhaps it was because the experience
was not only novel but in some way
impersonal
looking down the dark tunnel of the
aircraft at the double line of soldiers
it was a relief to see that all traces
of nervousness had disappeared we had
been waiting a long time for this so
that is the opening of a book called men
at Arnhem and it was actually sent to me
by a guy by the name of James of Fenelon
and the book was originally published
under the pseudonym Tom Angus and it was
about this battle at this place called
Arnhem which is in Holland and in the
book the units that are doing the
fighting they're not identified they
don't say what units they are but
shortly after the book was published it
became very clear and it was revealed
that the author was an individual named
Jeffrey Powell a British Army officer
and that the unit that the book talks
about was the hundred and fifty sixth
parachute battalion of the British Army
who fought against all odds and really
with misfortune after misfortune for
eight days during Operation Market
Garden which is a famous World War two
operation a bold and super aggressive
plan and also the largest airborne
operation up until that point and the
goal was to isolate parts of the German
forces and to cut off what's known as
the Ruhr district which is like the
heart of German industry and then open
up a route going from through that whole
area take control of the roads and the
bridges and be able to punch right into
the heart of Germany over 40,000
airborne troops took part in the
operation including
America's 82nd airborne and the hundred
and first Airborne Division's but the
deepest that those that jump deepest
into enemy territory were from the
British British 1st Airborne Division
and that included this battalion the
hundred and 56th parachute battalion and
if you know anything about Operation
Market Garden although it did achieve
some beneficial things overall the
mission was considered a failure because
it didn't actually achieve the
objectives that it wanted to achieve and
as you can imagine those that were
furthest out suffered some absolutely
catastrophic casualties and people taken
prisoner and people killed in action and
and this is only an eighth day this is
eight days long so this is this period
that we're about to cover is only eight
days long and you're gonna see that it
is it is vicious and the names were
changed in this book but again this is
an accountant an account from one of the
company commanders inside this battalion
so obviously the opening was them flying
over to the English Channel and getting
ready to jump in to Holland and here we
go back to the book I braced myself at
the open door the first man in the stick
to jump gripping the fuselage and in
case a sudden jerk flung me out too soon
leaning forward the wind whipped my face
poring over the details of the Placid
Dutch landscape below I could now see
one or two cyclists dotting the
otherwise deserted countryside the
flicker of the red warning light near my
face told me that there was one minute
to go
a railway line flashed below the pattern
of the woods was familiar as the view of
the stable-yard from the office window
the air photographs and the briefing
model of the ground had imprinted the
shapes on my mind
the pilots were dead on target more
often than not in the old days we had
been dropped astray but these Yanks
always learned from their mistakes I
never saw the red light turned to green
Harrison's hand slapped my shoulder I
was out of the door the slipstream hit
me flicking me sideways and I fell away
just catching a glimpse of Harrison in
the air above me and the tail of the
aircraft flashing out of sight then I
was floating suspended gently in midair
my parachute canopy high I looked up at
the sky choked with hundreds of swaying
parachutes
most of them patterned in green and
brown camouflage but other others in a
galaxy of colours red and orange purple
blue and yellow vivid against the
scattered white clouds every moment more
aircraft arrived arrived to disgorge
their cargos into the crowded air then I
noticed the humming we were being shot
at from the ground there were boats on
the drop zone something was badly wrong
and opposed landing with the enemy
firing as we hung from our parachutes
parachutes or tried to collect our
weapons before we could gather into a
cohesive force on the ground was
something new for us in the British
airborne
horses so as they're coming down they're
getting shot at he uses this term
throughout the book he calls the German
Bo Bo CH II and where it comes from from
what I gathered there's a French word
that means it could mean head like
kibosh or something like that and it
also can mean cabbage and so I guess
they're they're they're slang term
they're derogatory slang term was these
big-headed German big cabbage heads and
he reduced that down to this term Bush
and it's a common one for them to use
they used it a lot in World War one and
so this is this is a hangover from that
but you're gonna hear it throughout the
book that's how he's referring to the
Germans back to the book of sharp pain
burned the knuckles of my left hand
blood was seeping from my fingers a
bullet must have hit me grazed me anyway
but now the heathland was rushing up
raising my hands to lift the web's I
pulled and then hit the and then the
ground hit me with an uncomfortable jar
a bad landing I lay in the sunken road
listening to the bullets cracking
overhead and they're right there they
get right into the mix I mean it's
immediately into the mix obviously
they're getting shot out in the way down
and then what soon as they hit the
ground it's on back to the book a man
with blood strain bloodstains shale
dressing wrapped around his throat
walked around the corner of the warding
towards us just as Prichard who's the
medic finished his work then came a
couple of parties carrying stretchers
the occupant of one hung conscious the
other with a cigarette between his grey
tight lips they were the first stream of
wounded men from a variety of units
making their painful way towards the
dressing station which had been set up
in the wood behind us so far C Company
had been lucky only four men were
missing and a fifth that turned up late
smiling cheerfully despite a bullet
through his bandaged arm another four or
five were limping and hopping about on
strained or twisted ankles expressions
of disgust in their faces the
Timms of the gusty wind on the dropping
zone all of them would have to be left
behind but then I fought again
calculating the figures once more
perhaps we had not been so lucky after
all a tenth of the men who had in planed
that morning were already casualties it
it sounded as if all the fighting had
happened on the far side of the dropping
zone in the Arnhem direction now the
noise of the battle began to ebb the
enemy posts had probably been overrun
neither news nor orders had arrived from
battalion headquarters but I knew better
than to obstruct the radio net with
needless questions so first of all
you're rolling into a situation where
you you're on your insert and you lose
10% of your men that that's that's just
where you're starting now if I remember
correctly that is the standard kind of
figure that when you're conducting a big
airborne operation like when the army
conducts big airborne operations that's
what they figure they're gonna take for
casualties on the drop zone obviously
they usually do better than that but for
worst-case scenarios that's kind of what
they figure and that's where they're at
the other thing that I thought was cool
is here he is he hasn't heard any word
from the battalion HQ yet but he's not
gonna jump on the net and saying hey
boss what do you want me to do hey
what's going on hey where do you want to
be because there's other people that are
trying to talk and he's got to just kind
of figure things out at this point
now mmm he's talking about his own
company but here's the real portal and
on the rest of Italian as he learned as
he figures up and as usual obviously I'm
not reading the whole book and I'm
skipping through big chunks of combat
situations but at this point he figures
out what's going on with the battalion
going back to the book casualties in the
battalion had not been light to officers
and a hundred men had failed to arrive
among them
the plane load which we had seen shot
down another load had probably been
dropped in the wrong place Ian Hampshire
was one of the missing officers rumor
had it that he was dead the other was
the intelligence officer whose job Jimmy
I had now combined with his own Jimmy
could not explain the reason for the
delay
no one seemed to know and that's one of
the parts that I didn't go over in the
beginning of the book as they're flying
in as they're seeing flak hit and
explode around them he's you know they
see another one of their aircraft filled
with their brothers go down
no shoots now they start getting some
coherent input from the battalion and
here's what they figured out going back
to the book we would move as had already
been planned in England the leading
company of the battalion with Leslie
Doyle's platoon number nine in the front
some 200 yards ahead
followed by company headquarters then
Luke Tyler's 8th platoon then Douglas
Thompson 7 platoon at the back as I had
expected the company was ready to move
by the time orders had been given out
two minutes were all that was needed for
the men to slide their entrenching tools
into place pick up their weapons and
sort themselves out no one had removed
his equipment it was a lesson which the
colonel had drummed into us no man must
ever remove his equipment when the enemy
is anywhere near no matter whether he
was digging sleeping or defecating
whatever time it may be day or night a
soldier had only to reach for his weapon
to be ready to fight or to march just
once this day just once each day one man
in three at a time was allowed to strip
so that he could wash and shave and
shave they must the last man of nain
platoon was disappearing round the
corner of the sandy track which ran
parallel with the railway lying to
Arnhem when I noticed the colonel
standing on the right next to the shell
of a still smoking glider which partly
blocked the battalions path so there is
paratroopers that came in but other
people came in on gliders just big
gliders you know no engine that would
get towed by other planes they're filled
with men and they would just land these
gliders in in big open fields
gray was by the kernel side and behind
them crouched a knot of radio operators
and orderlies it was the same as ever
the Colonels eyes were still but he
never missed anything
the unfastened pouch from which a
grenade or Bren magazine could slip the
slack chin strap which would fail to
hold a running man's steel helmet in
place quietly the colonel would indicate
the error to whichever passing officer
or NCO was responsible for the man
nothing was ever ignored safely out of
range the offender would mumble about
the nitpicking old bastard but the abuse
was usually perfunctory and good-natured
all of them knew his ways and by now
they had learned that his fads mattered
so the Colonel's running a tight ship
hmm I think that's what he's doing he's
a highly disciplined guy and he keeps
his keeps his troops in check and as you
can see they're not offended by that
like they they they complain about it a
little bit but they also they also know
it's the right thing to do here we go
back to the book although we were moving
along our planned route our role in the
battle had been changed instead of
making for the high ground north of
Arnhem the whole of the brigade was now
marching for the for the bridge to
relieve the struggling remnants of the
1st Brigade which had been fighting
alone there for more than 24 hours one
thing was certain so so there their
mission had changed a little bit there's
a bridge and 1st Brigade was at this
bridge had taken the bridge but now
they're getting attacked at that bridge
by the Germans and there and now these
guys get this brigade gets the orders to
go and help them go and relieve them
back to the book one thing was certain
parachute infantry were not the fast
moving hard-hitting troops depicted by
the daily press with no more transport
in a battalion than for lightly armored
carriers and some half dozen jeeps
nearly everything needed in battle
either had to be carried on the backs of
soldiers or dragged behind them there
were no trucks just behind the forward
companies loaded
spare ammunition instead extra
bandoliers were strung around necks and
light anti-tank mines swung from waist
belts success came with surprise in this
sort of fighting the enemy must be
caught unaware and crushed before they
could recover inevitably we would run
short of ammunition
if the Bose were allowed the chance of
standing and fighting this weary trudged
toward the bridge and Arnhem along the
endless tracks was a crazy way to use
airborne troops surprise had been lost
long ago before the operation started I
doubted the wisdom of dropping so far
from the bridges now it was clear that
it had been a mistake so there there in
a radically different situation instead
of dropping in and holding some ground
now they're moving they have to carry
all their gear with them it's it's not a
good situation he's talking about some
of the guys are carrying it as much as a
hundred pounds which is a ton of weight
and now they get they get word from the
colonel back to the book he was able to
confirm that the 1st parachute Brigade
was still holding out at the bridge
where the casualties had been heavy on
both sides
the Germans having already lost 2,000
men although it was not clear who had
counted them now as he gets done with
that he kind of gives some word they're
gonna start moving down this track so
he's giving that order to this one of
his officers Doyle and Doyle's normally
you know pretty pretty fired up about
what he's doing he's a motivated guy and
here we go back to the book Doyle was
not at all his in bullion self the task
of nine platoon was simple he and his
men had to walk straight down the track
until they ran into the bush position
their first warning of the enemy
presence would be the rifle and machine
gun fire tearing into them still less
were the two Scouts to be envied who
would be moving out
front of the rest of the platoon it was
almost inevitable that the first German
rounds would hit one or both of them
unless the Germans were cunning enough
to let them pass so as to kill more of
the men behind but without armor in
front to draw the enemy fire and
pinpoint their positions there was no
other way to advance I had chosen Doyle
to lead the advance because I was
certain that I could rely on him
this was the penalty for being good at
one's job so there you go they're
actually walking down train tracks and
they know a hundred percent they know a
hundred percent that Germans are waiting
for them and they're gonna push down
these tracks and the way they're gonna
find the Germans is when the Germans
start shooting at them so they proceeded
down the tracks and now going back to
the book the expected happen happened
the calm of the night collapsing an
explosion of light and noise from a wide
arc in front of nine platoon streams of
white red and yellow tracer bullets
converged on the stretch of track where
the men must have flung themselves to
the ground very lights and parachute
flares larger and brighter than anything
carried by us swung down towards the
earth
lighting the dark country shy to the
shade of grey of a gray November morning
a house burst into flames on the other
side of the railway it was too sudden
for an accident the conflagration must
have been planned anything which moved
was now visible over all was the noise
the din of shells and mortars bursting
both behind and ahead merging with the
harsh roar of this enemy spanned a light
machineguns and the more sustained
drumming of the heavier weapons now I
could hear another sound it was a slow
rat-a-tat-tat of nine platoons Bren guns
and the crack of British rifles replying
to the German fire there are a lot of
enemy in front of us
the Germans had men everywhere so this
is like a well planned ambush scenario
and if you think about it they had it
sounds like they rigged this house to
light up and and be on fire and now
that's backlighting and Silla waiting
all the friendly troops because it just
makes you stand out because there's a
fire behind you on top of that
machine-gun fire on top of that mortars
shells are hating you and here we go
back to the book as as as the major here
as the company commander Jeffrey Powell
is is crouched down waiting as all this
is happening out ahead of him he's not
with that 1st platoon he's behind them a
little bit and here we go back to the
book I saw a single crouched figure
running up the track behind towards me
then I recognize the broad bulk of barf
Bartholomew Leslie Doyle's platoon
sergeant this was quick Leslie had
wasted no time in sending back news only
a little out of breath
sergeant Bartholomew sank down by my
side and began to speak his voice is
calm and sensible as usual his leading
section come under fire at a range of
only some 20 or 30 yards it appeared
that the Germans had allowed the two
Scouts to pass unmolested but everyone
else in the front section had been
killed there were several other
casualties in the platoon as well
including mr. Doyle who had been hit
badly in the thigh and was only
semi-conscious the survivors were pinned
to the ground by fire which was coming
from either side of the track this was
all wrong with his platoon commander hit
sergeant Bartholomew his place was with
the platoon there were plenty of other
people to carry messages not only that
but Bartholomew could hardly have had
time to verify the disastrous
information about the leading section it
was far too late far from likely that
every man and it had been killed
so Bartholomew's nerve
had broken in the first test so that's
the situation this guy ran hmm and he
comes back and reports in and says you
know hey everyone's dead and he realizes
he realizes the company commander
realizes that not true going back to the
book perhaps the responsibility had been
too much for him whatever it was he was
certainly scared despite his success in
concealing the fact the sergeant had run
away leaving the platoon to its own
devices I was flabbergasted of all the
NCOs I had judged this cool reserved man
to be the most dependable a hard
taskmaster too ruthless to be popular
sergeant bartholomew had been an
effective foil to the easygoing and
friendly Doyle and the two men had
formed a fine team it was incredible
that this should have happened in the
light of a flare I studied the
sergeant's face there was nothing to be
seen Bartholomew returned my glaze with
steady eyes there could be no point in
my further destroying the man's self
self-respect it was possible that he
might recover after this first shock his
pride taking charge to control his fear
so my rebuke was restrained no more than
a comment that Bartholomew should have
sent private Jones back with the news
and not come himself then I stood up
once again told Robert who had appeared
by my side to take charge and started
down the track toward the forward
platoon motioning Bartholomew to
accompany me there was no need to say
anything to harrison who automatically
rose to his feet his stand cradled in
his elbow ready to shoot so interesting
leadership dynamic there instead of
saying yo you coward or do you quit he
doesn't do that instead he he really
tones it back and says you should have
said Jones instead he's hoping that this
guy will recover and this is a great
line his pride taking charge to control
his fear meaning this guy just has
pride at this point he's trying to keep
it together but hopefully the cap the
the company commander is thinking that
okay this guy will get it back together
hopefully and we'll be able to utilize
him as opposed to me just dropping the
hammer on him right now
in which case he might just completely
break and be worthless and the other
thing and I I tried to include as much
as I could of this guy Harrison that
gets mentioned who's sort of the the the
company commanders right-hand guy but
he's just always there always ready
always stepping up and making things
happen mm-hmm now eventually as all that
unfolds we're going back to the book
Nesbitt which is one of the guys in that
in that platoon Nesbitt had decided that
it was time to leave and had used the
Lowell to bring back the survivors of
the platoon two men were dead while
nothing was known of the fate of the two
Scouts with Nesbitt were five wounded
men two of whom including his officer
were being carried Leslie in shocking
pain from a shattered Phi which morphia
had done little to help had fainted
after a few yards and was still
unconscious a third of the platoon were
casualties it was bad but not as quite
as bad as pictured by Barr following you
I could not blame Nesbitt for
withdrawing without permission short of
ammunition with her officer wounded and
the platoon sergeant unaccountably
missing the men had heard nothing of the
troops behind them for the past hour and
had concluded that the battalion must
have pulled back Nesbitt had seen a lot
of war as his DC m1 and Crete
testified he understood its muddled he
knew it was rare for a battle to go as
planned his responsibility was to his
men to rescue them from what seemed to
be a mess this he had done and his
judgment had been correct they were no
place to be caught at daylight
overlooked on a forward slope and on
cumbered with wounded men so you see
decentralized command in action right
there Nesbitt doesn't here doesn't know
what's going on he makes a decision I'm
getting these guys out of here and
what's good is the company commander
supports it hey he made a good call that
was the right thing to do now at this
point they're moving back they're moving
back after they've confirmed
you know they pushed forward trying to
find out where the Germans were and now
they're moving back because they realize
that the Germans are absolutely holding
strong so they've done this push forward
they've got it basically ambushed and
now they'd pulled back after you know
like I said confirming where the Germans
were back to the book to accomplish this
meaning to accomplish finding out where
the Germans were to accomplish this had
cost us Leslie Doyle and the absent
Bartholomew while two men in Doyle's
leading section were dead and the two
scouts were missing probably either
killed or made prisoner seven other men
had been wounded including another
sergeant this is a total of 13
casualties with another nine men lost
when we landed with nothing at all
accomplished over 20 men had already
been killed or injured and now the
battalion was moving in the wrong
direction back the way we had come and
you're gonna you're gonna find them and
this is what makes this story so so
devastating is that it you know I talked
about Murphy's Law and things go wrong
these guys are complete it's it's just
Murphy's Law over and over again and in
most of the books that we read on here
there's triumph and there's a victory at
the end and and you can see right now
already where this is heading we got 20
guys wounded or killed and instead of
moving forward we're actually moving
backward mm-hmm back to the book sooner
than expected we reached the battalion
base and had been cited in a rectangular
patch of wood about 20 acres inside
lying just north of the railway
it was 2:30 a.m. a horrible hour
especially so if one is tired cold and
hungry thank God it would be starting to
get light in a couple of hours what
would happen tomorrow something had gone
very wrong indeed by now we should be
dug in on the high ground north of
Arnhem waiting for the Germans to
counter-attack the bridges instead we
were sitting here in the woods only a
few miles from where we had dropped with
strong enemy forces between ourselves in
the city where the men of 1st Brigade
must be fighting for their lives
wherever one turned there seemed to be
German troops and good ones at that the
men who had stopped us and not behaved
like rear area troops scraped together
to put up some sort of resistance but it
fought with skill and tenacity the slit
trenches were dug and everyone except
for the double centuries in each section
and the officers and NCOs on duty was
sound asleep the men humped like dogs
some curled up with a companion for
warmth lying in their full equipment
their weapons tied to their wrists by
the slings I should be asleep too not
sitting and worrying feeling sorry for
myself but trying to get some rest in
preparation for the coming day stand -
would be at zero for 30 hours half an
hour before first light when everyone
would be awake and ready in his slit
weapon poised for a possible dawn attack
[Music]
so they're dug in and of course it's not
looking good at this point they're gonna
stand to at 0 4:30 which is pretty
common gonna be up before the sunrise
and you want to be up before the enemy
as well now they get together and get
some word here we go back to the book it
did not take long he did not take the
colonel long to give us our orders the
brigade was to renew its effort to reach
the bridge and bring relief to the men
still fighting there so pretty simple
straightforward goal and in order to
achieve this goal they set up to do an
attack on this little section of woods
where they think there's a bunch of
Germans and here we go back to the book
the leading sections plunged into the
wood and disappeared there were no enemy
there at all the information from
Brigade must have been wrong we had
attacked and taken an empty position
never was there such an anti-climax but
never was an anti-climax more welcomed
now we get a little visit up on the
front lines here we go back to the book
as the small spare figure stepped out of
the first vehicle I realized that it was
the first time I had seen the Brigadier
commander since we left England he was
just the same as ever
relaxed and smiling battle was nothing
new to him he'd been through the worst
of the desert war muddle in no way
disconcerted him at least not outwardly
it's interesting he uses the term
muddled mmm he's talking about the fog
of war this model when you don't really
know what's happening he talks about how
the veterans are used to it in a common
and accustomed to it and they can deal
with it
muddled in no way disconcerted him at
least not Howard Lee he seemed to
anticipate it
understanding how judgment and behavior
was impaired by danger wherever he went
he inspired confidence with his gentle
eyes and friendly manner
for regular cavalry officer his
background was unusual he'd come to his
regiment not from Sandhurst but from
Oxford
with a double first and fluency and a
half a dozen languages and I love this
line right here he wore his learning
light neat lightly as he did his
decorations meaning this guy is highly
educated and highly decorated but you
don't even know it it was rare for
soldiers to be aware of officers more
senior than the Colonel's who commanded
their battalions but every man in the
brigade would recognize could recognize
a name to brigadier the two visitors did
not stay long but their appearance was a
tonic for all it was a reminder that
that there were able men in charge even
though the battle was developing in a
rather odd manner
[Music]
now as they as he continues in these
situation back to the books suddenly my
preoccupation my preoccupation with the
problems of others ceased there was a
familiar whine overhead and I found
myself propelled into the half-dug
trench all but on top of Galbraith and
Robert the action had been reflex I knew
that I had made no conscious decision to
jump as I lay there with my
second-in-command entrenching tool
carving into a ridge in my left buttock
the mortar bomb burst about eight feet
to the right the scream of the shards of
jagged metal passing just overhead
flailed my ears as earth and stones
spattered down on top of us the stench
of high-explosive filled my filled the
trench my face I found was pressed into
the coarse material of corporal
Galbreath battle trousers gingerly
raising my head I peered over the low
parapet at the foot of the Java tree
some 15 yards away lay motionless heap a
green and khaki bundle which did not
stir jumping out of the trench I ran
across and turned over the limp body the
head fell back to show the open staring
eyes of sergeant hauk's one of the seven
platoon section commanders a bright
young NCO only just promoted who had
been with the battalion since the day it
was raised he was another old friend
at first I could see no sign of injury
but then I noticed the small hole in the
back of Hawkes helmet and the thin
stream of blood streaking the back of
his neck lying by hug inside I seemed to
count seven explosions all just a little
further away than the first but still
close enough to smell the hot gases
there was a short pause and then as if
it were not afterthought an eighth bomb
struck the branches of the tree just
above us directing its hot metal
splinters down to the trenches below a
half strangled his cry of distress
brought my head up just in time to see
corporal Prichard clamber out of his
slit and raychel race across the towards
the cry his haversack of medical
supplies marked with its red cross
from his hand the pause lasted no more
than a half a minute
again the wine again I ducked this was
the covering fire for a counter-attack
or the was this the covering fire for a
counter-attack or were the Bose merely
harassing us spitefully but when I
raised my head from Higgins from Huggins
boots to look around I was relieved to
see one of the seven platoon Bren
Gunners his helmet and eyes just above
the level of the parapet gazing down the
track towards his front
so the sentries were still doing their
job the fire was not forcing their heads
down if they're if this was the covering
fire for an attack we would not be
caught unawares so that's the standard
procedure right here for the Germans and
really for anyone its cover and move
right we put in big bombs we put in
mortars we put it on in artillery and
while you're hiding and while you're
ducking down so you don't get killed
they maneuver it and then write it right
when they get so close that they're in
danger of their own artillery the
artillery stops and then they proceed
with the assault mmm here we go
the low now there's a lull valo provided
a chance to finish digging there was no
longer any need to persuade the pen to
dig faster the lesson had really been
driven home we've been dating for no
more than a few minutes when the sound
of firing to the north slackened but the
noise from the vehicles in front had
increased the thought of guns only a few
hundred yards away was punctuated by the
hammering of bren's by the way Brens I
don't think I've said this friends are
sort of the a weapon of British machine
gun versus the the span now which is
which is the German machine guns and we
they use the Brits and the Americans
used the term Spandau to talk about
basically heavy machine heavier machine
guns but but that's what they're talking
about when they talk about spend out and
then a brand is the Brit machine gun
both forward platoons were in action and
I had placed company headquarters too
far back to be able to see what was
happening the walkie-talkies were silent
also I worried about the city
the platoons some 300 yards apart each
isolated in its own corner of the woods
and unable to support the others against
a determine attack this is so important
for tactical leaders out there think
about these lessons and these are
lessons that I talk about all the time
and these are lessons that I used to
have to teach all the time so you've got
your platoons they're out there doing
something you need to be close enough
that you have communications with them
so that you actually understands what's
happening and this is the same in the
business world if you put yourself in a
position where you can't anyway you
don't understand what's happening in the
field then you're not gonna be able to
help you're not gonna be able to support
you're not gonna be able to to
understand what's happening so you can
make decisions mmm so in this point he's
positioned himself too far away on top
of that he's positioned his platoons too
far apart from each other so if you're
too far apart from each other you can't
cover for each other
if you can't cover you can't move and if
you can't move you can't win so those
are critical points make sure your
command position is close enough not so
close that you're getting in the
firefight no not so close that you're
pinned down but close enough so that you
understand what is happening and then if
you have multiple elements in the field
do you get them close enough to each
other that they can support each other
mmm always he sees a guy running back
and here we go back to the book it was
Sergeant Pryor one of Nesbit's section
commanders a rather sulky man able and
well educated but with a grudge against
authority in his left hand prior grasped
his Sten in a grip so firm that the
knuckles showed blue under his under the
sunburn his right arm from which
clothing had been cut away at the
shoulder was thrust into the front of
his smock
with shock and taught with pain a
morphia injection was doing little to
alleviate the agony of an elbow smashed
by a bullet the news prior brought was
serious the vehicles which we could hear
were
armored driving backwards and forward
along the road and sweeping the front of
nine platoons position secure from
retaliation so far the armor had only
claimed prior but sergeant Avondale had
been killed by a mortar fragment as he
dashed across between a couple of trees
to put some question to Nesbitt this
inexorable loss of skilled leaders was
serious in our parachute battalions
unlike usual infantry units section
leaders ranked as sergeants not
corporals nine platoon had now lost not
only its officer but three of its four
sergeants as well Hawkes was dead and
one of seven platoon section commanders
had failed to appear at the rendezvous
after the drop already nearly half the
sergeants had become casualties
this is just a nightmare unfolding back
to the book after we'd put the final
touches on our slit trenches time was
found to scrape a shallow grave for
sergeant hauk's it was hard to suppress
ones revulsion at touching the body of
someone I had known so well but just as
I was stealing myself to do so huginn
step forward ripped open the dead man
smock and shirt and slipped one of the
two identity disks over the
blood-stained head the sergeant major
then unbuckled his watch and searched
the pockets for anything which might be
useful a Morpheus syringe and a field
dressing a bar of chocolate and a couple
of mils grenades two packets of
cigarettes in a box of matches a couple
of maps in a pocket knife there was
nothing personal except for a grubby
envelope containing a half a dozen faded
and dog-eared snapshots of a stout
smiling girl holding a baby before
buttoning the envelope into his breast
pocket hug and slipped the identity disc
between the photographs I was helping
corporal Pritchard shoveled the earth
back over Hawkes body listening with one
ear two hug and sharing the dead man's
ammunition and other possessions among
the members of the company headquarters
when suddenly I became aware of Jamie
grey standing beside me apparently
anxious to speak but differed diffident
and interrupting telling Pritchard to
finish the job I rose from my knees glad
to be able to vote my mind to something
else when I turned to speak to grey I
was disturbed by what I saw the dirt of
battle had exaggerated his usual
scruffiness his smock and trousers were
coated with mud and dust and his right
sleeve was stained from top to bottom
with blood not his own as he explained
when he saw my eyes fixed on it the
front of his smock and the battle dress
underneath had been torn by a large
fragment of a mortar bomb which in some
miraculous fashion had failed to even
scratch him
three inches to one side and it would
have been set and it would have severed
his head but it was the eyes above the
pallid unshaven cheeks which were
frightening they were empty of life when
he spoke the words were lucid and
well-chosen as ever but the voice lacked
expression the phrases were cold it was
not as if we were describing events
which he had himself witnessed but
something unreal something half imagined
B company it attacked at zero 800 hours
at the start there advanced through the
woods had gone like the first attack in
the morning a calm and steady progress
against the seemingly non-existent enemy
then some hundred yards short of the
objective a swath of fire had cut down
the men of the two leading platoons the
half grown trees and the sparse
undergrowth had neater
neither hidden them nor shielded them
from the interlocking arcs of the enemy
weapons which covered every inch of
ground it was just possible that they
might have been able to deal with the
machine guns alone but the armour was
too much for them pumping shells into
the men at near point blank range gray
had seen it all happen the colonel had
tried to stop the attack as soon as the
full strength of the enemy position had
become clear but by then more than half
the men of the two leading platoons had
been killed or wounded both subalterns
were dead
the other officers and the CSM had all
been wounded the colonel had tried to
turn the German flank by sending a
company around to the left but there was
no flank the second attack had been a
replica of the first it too had
collapsed but not before some forty more
men were dead or maimed including two of
the four surviving officers Harry Bates
had been terribly wounded in the stomach
and by now was probably dead
as gray had pulled him behind some cover
his blood had soaked his sleeve this was
not the complete story there was further
bad news not only had our own attack
been shattered but the other battalion
to our north had hit similar enemy
positions and was making little progress
progress in its efforts to get into
Arnhem along the main road from
somewhere or other the Bose had found
enough troops of quality good enough to
smash the brigades attempt to reach the
city so we just have a horrible
situation unfolding back to the book
from far away in the distance came the
drum of powerful aeroplane engines
Nesbitt was the first to spot the minut
shapes first circling and then diving
out of the Sun towards us the noise
changing to a shriek as the machine
swept down towards the wood towards the
woods from a half a dozen different
directions a happy shout of Spitfires
rose from the trenches at lasts some
help and arrived from the outside world
the RAF had arrived to give us close air
support and that's you know we've had
close air support save the day many
times in in in books that we've talked
about on this podcast hmm as I gave up
at the dozen spits screaming down to
strafe the Bose positions on the sloping
ridge head Nesbitt's voice suddenly
roared in my ear shouting to everyone to
get their heads down and hide their
faces as I ducked with the rest I
spotted the black crosses on the wings
the aircraft were not ours
but German Messerschmitts our air
superiority was so overwhelming that it
never occurred to anyone that the
machines might be hostile they were not
diving onto the enemy positions but on
to our own
I gazed skywards the messerschmitt was
so close that I could see the pilots
face two Rockets detach themselves from
the wings and swoop down to explode
seconds later in the woods where the
survivors of a and B companies were
settling into their new positions as I
ducked once more there was another
scream of engines from behind followed
by the sound of a storm of bullets
striking branches on the trees and the
other side two aircraft which had
discharged their rockets were now
carrying out a second run strafing with
their machine guns as I squeezed even
closer to the earth at the bottom of the
shallow trench the reverberations of an
explosion some fifty yards of ways
pounded my eardrums
it was another rocket suddenly it ended
the aircraft had vanished as quickly as
they had arrived Wow yeah because at
this point the the the British and the
Americans had almost total air
domination and so everyone just
completely assumed that of thank God
here comes some Spitfires to come and
save us and they were wrong
now the the air we did have air
domination for the most part and one of
the things that they needed as you as
you heard these airborne troops they can
only carry so much and so they're gonna
need re supplies they need more
ammunition they need medical gear they
need food they need water they need
stuff to be dropped to them and so there
was a plan in place for them to have
gear and food and equipment and
ammunition dropped to them at these
locations where they were supposed to be
mm-hmm because remember they were
supposed to be making progress this
whole time they're not making progress
but they are supposed to be making
progress and and since communication is
so bad they can't call back and say hey
we're not were supposed to be were over
here drop the gear on us hmm but the
gear gets dropped in the pre-planned
positions which of course our enemy
positions
but here's what it sounds like for them
or here's what they're thinking on the
ground then to the south of us I saw the
familiar shape of a line of Dakota's
approaching at about a thousand feet in
a minute the sky was crammed with them
it was the first Supply Drop about which
we had been told that the briefings but
the drop zone was a couple miles away
over the other side of the hill right in
the middle of enemy positions by now of
course the division should have captured
the area but the bow still held it news
of the progress of the battle could not
have reached the raf or the pilots would
have diverted to drop their supplies
elsewhere now they can see this
happening and the people that are in the
planes they're called the Ras see the
Royal Army Service Corps they run
basically the supply and the logistics
and and help resupply and drop this
equipment so this is he's as he's
watching all these Dakotas the Dakotas
are these little transport planes it's
actually what they had parachuted out of
and now they're watching them drop this
resupply back to the book among the mass
a single Dakota just overhead caught my
attention it had already been hit and
flames were creeping down from the
starboard engine toward the cockpit as
it lost height the khaki clad Ras sea
dispatchers were standing at the open
doorway pushing out the panniers of
supplies those are the bags of supplies
I could see their faces the fire was on
their side of the plane the wing was
burning before their eyes the Dakota was
now little more than 300 feet above the
ground if the men at the door jumped now
they might just save themselves in a
second or two more the aircraft would be
so low that their parachutes would not
have time to open this the men must have
known
but they went on with their routine
drill pushing out the panniers
regardless of what would happen to them
then the starboard wing crumpled the
flaming plane disappeared beyond the
trees the panttiere is still falling
from the open door the sky was empty the
last plane had gone but we still stood
watching the place where the Dakota had
vanished mourning the futility of the
self-sacrifice we had just witnessed
[Music]
can't even imagine that guys just
continuing to do their job knowing their
fate at their their senior officers at
this point and their NCOs are starting
to get hit pretty regularly by snipers
and so he decides he tells his his guys
hey take your take your rank off your
uniform because I don't want the enemy
to know and he tells us to one of his
one of his leaders name named Robert and
he says as I watched Robert slip his
captain stars off his shoulders and
tucked them away in his pocket I knew
for certain that my second-in-command
disapproved officers should show
themselves as such so one of his guys is
they can know we're officers we need to
we need to stand out we need to stand up
now I mentioned the American forces the
82nd and 101st and the British forces
there was also a Polish parachute
Brigade that was coming in on this
attack as well and they were scheduled
to come in a little bit later as
reinforcements and here we go back to
the bank book only then did I remember
that the glider-borne part of the Polish
parachute brigade was due to land
afternoon upon the stretch of enemy upon
the stretch of open country below us at
the same time as the parachute
battalions were dropped in the polder
land south of Arnhem bridges the landing
zone was already a battlefield and the
wretched poles were about to land in the
middle of it first the gliders hit the
ground its massive weight tearing up
chunks of stubble as it skidded to a
halt lurching on to one wing as it did
so men jumped out and rushed to the rear
and to release the tail unit so that the
vehicles inside could be driven out to
more gliders were now plowing across the
ground another exploded in the air and a
vast ball of yellow flame just as it was
upon the point of touching down mortar
bombs were bursting among the men
struggling to release their loads while
streams of chase tracer bisected the
scene in two oddly formal patterns
another glider was on fire on the ground
as still more swooped in to land adding
to the chaos the poles were now joining
in the battle themselves some firing
toward the Germans some towards the Kos
B which is a the King's Own Scottish
Borders it's an it's another British
unit and some in the direction of our
other battalion it must be impossible
for the poles to distinguish enemy from
friends they probably thought they had
landed in a circle of Boetsch units all
intent upon their destruction in a few
minutes it was all over from the wrecked
and flaming gliders which now littered
the ground small parties of poles were
making their escape firing at anything
they saw move two or three vehicles have
been driven away but otherwise they had
failed to drag their jeeps and guns from
the gliders the Polish anti-tank battery
no longer existed as a fighting unit it
had landed in the middle of a battle and
been destroyed before it could fire a
single shot waste it was waste once
again waste like the Supply Drop nothing
seemed to go right a knot of some eight
poles charged towards us intent on
seeking shelter either in the woods or
behind the safety of a railway
embankment some 30 yards away one man
slightly ahead of the others must have
noticed our camouflage steel helmets in
slit trenches ahead and shouted a
warning in a bunch they flung themselves
into the undergrowth anticipating what
would happen I yelled to everyone to get
their heads down just as a hail of
bullets from the polls whistled over our
heads
a few hitting the trench parapets but
most striking the trees well above our
heads as the excited men emptied their
weapons in our direction so long as we
kept our heads down we were safe from
the Polish fire but the worry was that
some of them might creep closer and
start to fling grenades around however
in a couple of minutes the firing
slackened and then ceased possibly the
pols sense that something might be wrong
when no one retaliated the comparative
silence provided the opportunity to
shout a warning across the narrow
stretch of ground which separated us
there was no reply and I shouted once
again in faltering English a voice
inquired who we were firmly the company
sergeant major Huggins told them the
polls seem to understand after a few
seconds of audible consultation they
rose to their feet and walked across so
you've got a just a chaotic situation
the pols land they're getting attacked
from all directions and sure enough
they're shooting at the friendly forces
blue-on-blue
happening once he gets them settled down
he's got some people some of these
Polish folks that now have no leadership
back to book calling Douglas / I told
him that he now had a fourth section in
seven platoon and within a few minutes
the poles were digging hard under the
tutelage of their corporal the only
comprehensible part of whose name
sounded like Peter the digging had
hardly started when a Jeep roared down
the track in the direction from the
direction of the battalion headquarters
as it braked to stop in the cover of the
trees Jimmy gray jumped out and ran
towards us Gray's news was startling we
were all to withdraw to wolfe hazen in
15 minutes time one could not just stand
up and walk away from an enemy right on
one's heels in daylight the only way to
withdraw was to move by bounds with
platoons and companies covering one
another back
any other plan was madness things over
in the North must be bad indeed for the
colonel to be rushed in this way but
Grey's instructions were unshakable so
they're digging in they're gonna order
get out of here we're gonna leave and
he's saying okay that's fine but guess
what even when you leave you still use
the fundamental principle of cover and
move and that's what he's wanting to do
so now they're on the retreat and here
we go back to the book the pace was far
too quick some men were all but running
to keep up as I had expected little by
little cohesion was starting to break
down some of the men of the mortar
platoon had overtaken us despite the
weight of the loads and were mixed and
among us there were two small groups
from another unit in the middle of seven
platoon from somewhere in the front a
long way off a span dowel spent senate's
bullets flying harmlessly overhead but
men were looking apprehensive and
flinching we were now under fire from
two different directions at any minute
the bush would find the range and then
the slaughter would begin it was no
longer an orderly retreat the withdrawal
was taking on the nature of a horde of
men seeking safety soon discipline would
crack and everyone would start to run
what a target we must be some 500 men
from four or five different units
rapidly coalescing into a solid moving
mass yeah this is just a nightmare
and you can imagine it's an individual
thing and you're gonna see some great
leadership examples but it's an
individual thing because if you can keep
the teams working together covering and
moving for each other that's good you're
gonna keep the enemy's heads down but if
if people and the group start saying you
know what I'm not gonna cover I'm gonna
run yeah and now no one's covering and
now you've got a bunch of people that
are moving and no cover and that's when
you're gonna get slaughtered not only
gonna get slaughtered by by people that
are shooting at you but if you're not
putting down a cover fire the enemy
maneuvers they don't just sit there I
mean some of them we shooting but
they'll be shooting but other elements
of them are gonna move and they're gonna
be able to cut you off they finally do
make it back and again I get a little
bit of luck here here we go back to the
book we caught our breath in the wood so
they get to a woods
David's men had disappeared and there
was no sign of the colonel or of the
battalion headquarters no one had
followed us we were the last across but
a quick check told me that only Robert
Watson the CSM and three or four other
men were missing in addition to seven
platoon of the latter there was nothing
to be seen in all there were still about
50 men with me
not counting Peter and his seven poles
still clinging tenaciously to us perhaps
I should try to get back across the
bullets pattered embankment to find out
what had happened to the others but the
noise of the battle was getting louder
the bush must be closing in the vital
thing must be to rejoin the rest of the
battalion with the fifty men I still had
and not to leave them and loop Tyler's
charge while I returned on what could be
a foolhardy errand but it was difficult
to avoid the thought that perhaps I was
reluctant reluctant to climb back over
the top of that embankment so he does
make it to this woods pleasin have
everybody with him and he's questioning
himself should I go back over there and
risk it or not mm-hmm and part of his
part of him is rationalizing you know I
had the best thing to do is get back
with the rest of battalion but part of
him is saying you're rationalizing this
and you're just you're just not you're
being a coward mm-hmm but he does he he
proceeds on all the time he knows he's
gonna get killed if he goes over that he
can hear the enemy coming so back to the
book ten minutes later we found the
remnants of the battalion half of a
company the mortars and what was left of
the machine guns were still or missing
as well as our own seven platoon more
than one-third of the men who had
withdrawn from the woods had failed to
cross the railway we were now down to no
more than a couple of hundred men so
that we're going we're down to a couple
of hundred men from five or six hundred
men in the battalion maybe even a little
bit more maybe there might have been
seven hundred men in the battalion they
get word once again here's what's going
to happen tomorrow at first light the
brigade would move on to Easter beak to
join the rest of the
vision but unless ammunition together
with air and artillery support was
forthcoming the prospects were far from
good we were it seemed not opposed by a
few third line troops elements of three
SS Panzer divisions had been identified
in the battle the Germans seemed to have
moved quickly or else something had gone
wrong with the intelligence it was not
surprising that the days fighting had
been so very bitter so they're pointing
out that they weren't going against you
know third-rate troops they were going
on against SS Panzer divisions the best
of the German soldiers in talking with
sergeant major Bauer and sergeant
Nesbitt before I reached Tyler's platoon
I had done my best to be as cheerful as
possible but it was plain that the two
NCOs realized that I was making the best
of things with Luke Tyler it was
different
I could not insult him by trying to
disguise our straights
I just told him the facts as I had
received them from the colonel possibly
it was a mistake quite suddenly the
failure of it all oppressed me in less
than 36 hours 2/3 of the battalion had
gone 15 rifle company officers had
landed only two were left 10 for certain
had either been killed or wounded the
chances of surviving another day were
small fatigue and hunger had drained me
there was a need to unburden myself
Luke was jr. in my rank but equal in
years and in any case it was easier to
confide in someone who was in many ways
a stranger even as I spoke I was ashamed
of this weakness but there was no
stopping quietly Luke gave me the
reassurance I needed the iron needed to
sustain oneself through such a day was
easily expended and I felt that I had
prolonged some of Luke's share
[Music]
so he he basically unloads to one of his
guys or to what to another another
officer below him in rank but what I
think is interesting about this is he
needed someone to talk to her he was
holding it all inside and wasn't say
anything and trying to look positive and
even he's looking at his guys as he's
telling them don't worry gents we're
gonna be okay and his guys are looking
at him like hey no we don't believe you
and so he has to he feels the need to
unload on someone and that's why you
know I I just think from my perspective
you you know we always talk about
relationships that you have on your team
and for sure in your platoon or in your
team it's really good to have someone
that you can just kind of unload on that
you know is professional enough to
bolster you up without getting dragged
down into your negativity and a lot of
times I've found if if you have someone
like that or maybe a couple people like
that in your team that you can talk to
well guess what sometimes they're going
to be bolstering your attitude and
sometimes you're gonna be bolstering
their attitude yeah and and so you gotta
you got to find someone like that that's
in your team that you can say man this
is this horrible this is going wrong and
some of that someone's gonna go hey you
know what it's not that bad we're gonna
get through it and then two or three
days later he might be coming to you and
saying hey this is a horrible situation
I can't believe this in your game saying
no man we're gonna be alright so I think
it's important and that's again we're
building relationships but that's one of
the reasons we build relationships they
get into a hold up position back to the
book on stand two rounds I found the
Polish trenches empty except for Peter
there corporal crouched grimly behind
his Bren the rest of the party had
vanished in the early hours sensing
perhaps the day and attached themselves
to an unlucky unit Peter explained
nothing but his embarrassment was clear
it was both unfair and pointless to
press him for details when either pride
or sense of duty had kept him there to
fight among strangers the fault of what
would have happened if the enemy had
attacked from this direction against a
position held by one solitary man was
chilling it was a mistake to trust rain
I had learned yet another lesson rely on
only those you knew again it's
interesting how he sometimes backs off
instead of pressing where are you guys
he knows like what what point is that
or when Bartholomew was was running away
he didn't press him super hard and
you're gonna get to Boyd there's
pointing here when he does press people
but here he's deciding he's not gonna do
it and the other interesting thing is
here it says I learned another lesson
rely you know not to trust strangers
rely on only those you know what you
have to do in those situations is you
have to put someone that you do trust in
bed them with these units that you don't
know so if he would have taken and he
gave these he gave that section to one
of his platoon commanders and said hey
you got another section now but maybe in
bed one more guy or two more guys in
there or split these guys up even more
so instead of seven and one big bulk you
put two or three there two or three
there two or three there and now you
split them up a little bit and you can
have better control over them it's weird
there's you know there's opportunity to
desert though and these guys took the
opportunity now the fighting rages on
and obviously I have to fast-forward
through some of it and they eventually
get into a little village a little small
village and they've they've taken down
they've taken some buildings and here we
go
they're in these buildings back to the
book we were in a mess the boats were on
the other side of the valley outnumbered
and outgunned us there was not the
slightest hope of reaching the back of
the breed line this way and to stay here
on this forward slope was impossible at
this rate we would all be dead or
wounded soon somehow I had to get the
survivors back up the hill but it was
near but it was a near insuperable
problem with the men scattered down
among the houses lawns and shrubberies
shot at everytime they moved someone
called from the side of the house as I
turned and looked private Gregory darted
across
to throw himself down beside me under
the dirt and two days scrub of beard
his face was grayish white he seemed
about to vomit as Gregory stammered out
his platoon commanders name I knew what
had happened lieutenant Tyler was dead
it must have happened just after we
parted Luke had been killed on the steep
garden path which led from the house
down the road
he'd had been hit by a sniper killed
outright by a bullet through the heart
within a couple yards of the place where
Gregory was lying possibly Luke had been
careless because he was still dazed but
he had to get back to his platoon and
the path was his only route so they had
been together and they'd been hit by a
some kind of artillery in the house and
it rattled him and then Luke had gone
out to get back back to his platoon and
when he left he got shot by a sniper
back to the book this was how officers
and NCOs were killed just doing their
routine job this was why casualties
among the leaders were so high all the
time that they were moving about
checking here encouraging their
backwards and forwards now besides
myself and only the quartermaster
sergeant Bower and Sergeant Winer were
left all the rest of the officers and
sergeants in the company had gone one
problem however had been solved the
remnants of Tyler's two forward sections
had mannered managed to extricate
themselves without waiting for orders
since last night private Gregory had
been in charge of one of the other
sections both the NCOs having been hit
the day before during that last mortar
stonk a bomb and fallen right on top of
the Corporal who was commanding the
other section blowing him and his Bren
gunner half to pieces
common sense had told the survivors to
quit and there had been no one to stop
them except Gregory who for the moment
was shaken by the sight of what had
happened to his friends and who in any
case lacked the authority to hold them
there no one else had been hit in a
scramble back
survivors were now sheltering in the
house so they're in these houses and for
the first time you're gonna hear the
company commander start to realize he's
got people at the breaking point back to
the book the others were as uneasy as I
was for the first time I was unhappy
about them until now
they'd endured the successive disasters
but the events of the morning had tried
them too far it had been yesterday once
again yet another failure failure
against an enemy who is far too strong
for us men were looking jittery some
could be well near their breaking point
as I gaze down the slope trying to spot
some activity among the Boetsch a
movement to the right caught my eye
about 20 yards away two of Kelly's men
were moving diagonally behind me
sheltered on the far side of the ridge
these are these are deserters my shout
made them hesitate and then stop after
two or three more steps for getting the
enemy I stood up and strode down towards
them no explanation was necessary this
surly guilt on their faces was enough
deliberately choosing words for effect I
cursed them in language rarely used by
officers towards their soldiers it was
enough
the two men turned back towards their
platoon so like I said sometimes he
there there he's dropping the hammer
these two guys are trying to desert and
he goes on and and drops the hammer on
him and gets them back with their
platoon back to the book in this mood
the men would never stand up to an enemy
attack even a mortar stonk could break
them I could see it happening first one
or two men would slip away like the two
I had just stopped and then a rush would
follow something drastic had to be done
no more than the occasional rifle bullet
was now coming over in fact no one had
been hit since we took our positions
along this Ridge
it seemed safe enough
standing up I began to walk along the
path towards the left of our position
for the first few steps I felt
wretchedly vulnerable but then an odd
exhilaration seized me for the first few
steps I felt wretchedly vulnerable but
then an odd exhilaration seized me not
too slowly and not too quickly I strode
deliberately toward the first group of
men grinning down at Lance Corporal
Williams I made some inept remark about
it being the wrong place for a company
clerk if I were to be hit it would
happen anyway now seem to be as good a
time as ever stopping at each group of
men I checked their firing positions and
made necessary changes then I was at the
end of Kelly's line and I started back
conscious that everyone was watching
there was a burst of machine-gun fire
well wide of us but I managed to avoid
flinching at it suddenly sergeant we
whiners voice harsh with concern was
yelling at me to get down demanding
angrily what I was playing at the spell
broke I was grateful for the excuse to
lower myself down beside him very
relieved that it was over the rage in
Winer's face dissolved into an
unaccustomed grin the corny dramatics
were over but they had served their
purpose the men had got a grip on
themselves so he basically stood up and
walked around and talked to everyone and
made himself visible it made himself
appear to not be scared to get the guys
heads back in the game until his
sergeant whiner yells at him and says
hey dude get down when these guys desert
like the deserters what did they go so
they can head back towards towards the
areas that have been secured so as this
beachhead you know we landed d-day June
6th this is now in September so you know
coalition forces or sort of Allied
forces had pushed into France so if you
could walk back you could eventually get
to friendly lines yeah and that's that's
what their plan
was and then what that when you get
there don't they know hey you d30 well
you tell I you know you'd say oh I was I
got separated from my tops when i
parachuted in I couldn't find my people
or whatever you met your lie and you
deal with it later with later cuz right
now you're thinking I'm not gonna make
it yeah just want that be it was clear
why nothing we had heard nothing from
battalion headquarters for the past two
hours like everyone else the signal II
the signalers orderlies and clerks had
been fighting for their own survival the
Germans were all around them and had
been pressing them hard throughout the
morning so they're not getting any
information about what's happening this
is this is interesting he goes back to
get they end up with a little extra
ammunition and he goes back to get some
ammunition from the battalion they have
got a leg stage and the battalion
headquarters and as he's doing this he
the the ammunition was in a Jeep and so
he goes to the Jeep he finds the Jeep
and he's with one of his other guys and
they're the regimental sergeant major is
sitting basically on top of the Jeep on
top of the ammunition and he kind of is
looking at the guy you know saying hey
I'm here I'm an officer I got platoons
out there and a company out there I got
to get them ammunition and he doesn't
really move he just kind of sits there
and so finally here he was but the here
the regimental sergeant major was in the
middle of battle sitting on his arse and
taking his ease while a company
commander hunted for ammunition majors
are not in the habit of rebuking
regimental sergeant majors but this was
too much the tensions of the morning had
snapped my self restraint and in a
couple of succinct sentences I told the
RS the regimental sergeant major one I
thought of him then the regimental
sergeant major apologized but he did not
move without any trace of irony or
annoyance in his voice he quietly
explained that he could not stand up
because he had been shot through both
legs I had not noticed the airborne Smok
with which someone had covered his
outstretched and
bandaged legs think before you act
now they're on their way
they're heading finally to this area of
oyster beak they're on their patrol and
here we go back to the book a spandau
opening up ahead sent us all to the
ground men diving for cover just a
little too quickly a moment later a
second gun fired on us from the right
but it was the it was the ominous rattle
of the tracked vehicles which chilled
the first one then another then two more
quite close and in front their engine
clatter rising above the din of the
machine gun and rifles then some seventy
yards away I saw the first of the ESPY
guns its stubby weapon traversing slowly
towards us Espie guns are they're kind
of like tanks it's it's self-propelled
guns they're like artillery pieces with
tracks on them hmm the flash from its
stout from its snout was one of with the
explosion of the bursting shell just to
the right a half-grown tree shattered
into jagged splinters a second shot
falling hard on the first one covered
Harrison and me with earth we were
swamped by the noise every sort of
weapon seemed to be firing grenades were
exploding but the distinct above the
rest was the Clank and the throaty COFF
of the armored guns caught like this in
the open we were helpless tanks plowing
among about among us could have been no
worse there was no way of fighting back
no one seemed to have even a pea out
which is like their bazooka anti-armor
weapon and we could not get close enough
to use the gamin bombs the bags of
plastic explosive carried for the for
use against Armour so that's another
little it's like a big bag of explosives
that you can put on a armored vehicle to
destroy it they call them gammon bombs
the men in front were moving again I
stood up in signaled those behind to
follow we were doubling now but there
was still some sort of control we were
not running away but making for
somewhere where I did not know
then about a hundred yards away I caught
a glimpse through the trees of a German
half track it stopped and helmeted
shapes jumped from its sides how many
more of them were there this could be
the start of another attack which could
only end it all our will to fight back
was all but broken then I heard the Brig
the Brigadier telling me to clear the
enemy out of the hollow after which the
survivors of the brigade would join us
there C Company it seemed was the last
organized body of troops so they're
looking at this area this open area
where there's some enemy but it looks
like it's a good position of course
their will to fight is just about broken
and you hear the Brigadier is saying hey
take your company and clear out that
Hollow go hmm
back to the book for a moment I was so
dumbfounded that I hardly heard the
Brigadier going on to say that the
brigade major was dead as well killed
about five minutes ago
another friend was gone but I hardly
listened what was the Brigadier ordering
us to do in his quiet and determined
fashion it was absurd the men were
finished only a few minutes ago I had
realized that they were past defending
themselves now we were being told to
assault that boast position the
brigadiers look was both quizzical and
encouraging the confounded man could see
what was passing through my mind then I
was away dodging back and through the
bushes towards the men in the ditch even
more aware than ever before of the
bullets singing overhead with my back to
a broad tree which hid me from the enemy
front I looked down at the upturned
faces there was no point in wasting at
all in wasting time on details the
orders I had to give them were quite
simple devoid of any complications such
as who would provide covering fire it
was time for play-acting again my
naturally loud voice carrying down the
line of men among the above the sound of
battles I balled at them to follow me
adding the comment that is better to be
killed going
for the pastors than lying in that
bloody ditch no one hesitated the man
rose to their feet at the moment I
stepped out into the open from behind
the shelter of the tree glancing to my
right I was exhilarated by the sight of
David Unwin solid bulk running parallel
to me and a half a dozen of his men
following David shouted something to the
effect that they were coming as well and
I waved my Sten gun and acknowledgement
behind me
sergeant whiner broke into a scream of
rage harsh and furious the yell spread
down the line too heavily laden and too
tired to sprint we lumbered forward
towards the enemy in a sort of jog-trot
now I was careless of everything we did
not stand a chance but this was the
right way to go this was the proper way
to finish it all nearly hysterical now
with rage and excitement I heard my own
voice join in the screaming the Germans
were shooting at us I could see flashes
of their weapons springing out of the
gloom of the trees there was no need to
look back to confirm that the line of
men was still following the noise told
me they were there now the boast were no
more than 50 yards away as I brought my
Sten down to hip level to press the
trigger it flashed through my mind that
it was the first time I had fired my
weapon since the battle started my
forefinger squeezed the metal nothing
happened it had jammed here I was
running toward the enemy with a useless
piece of metal in my hands there were
figures moving among the trees first a
couple then a half-dozen dark shapes
were outlined against the green
background men sprinting away men
disappearing through the trees the boats
were running away we had done it we had
driven the enemy out at the point of
bayonet this was the ultimate in war the
sight of the savage screaming
parachutists streaming towards them had
been too much for the Germans even
though they had to do nothing more than
keep their heads and shoot straight
[Music]
yeah so there you go
surrounded broken and I think key point
here when you're think you're broken do
something and do something aggressive
that's that's the D this is this is 100%
default aggressive that's what this is
you know what we're here we're being
defensive we're hiding in our slit
trenches okay you know what we're gonna
do we're going to attack we're going to
attack full force yeah back to the book
the site of David on the right added to
my delight shouting to him to hold the
right to the hollow I directed sergeant
whiner round to the left there was no
need to tell anyone to hurry they all
knew that the Germans would not delay in
mounting a counter-attack a moan of
terror distracted me I turned to the
wounded German the man's features were
contorted into a rictus of despair above
him stood sergeant major Kelly red eyed
and panting his bayonet raised above the
soldier's stomach but Kelly did not
strike he was relishing the moment
snatching maximum pleasure from the
wounded man's anguish before he sliced
it sliced into the soft belly as my
newly-found Mauser knocked the bayonet
to one side the sergeant major stalled
me in an unspoken protest at such silly
scruples then he seemed to shake himself
the bloodlust has bad past and he came
to his senses gathering his men to the
defenses so again he could this guy goes
from the pure fury and rage of this
incredible bayonet assault and then he
immediately just puts his one of his
sergeant majors in check who's about to
you know writ ruthlessly killed this
wounded guy mm-hmm
very interesting dichotomy there mm-hmm
back to the book something had been
snatched back from the disasters in the
day the remnants of the brigade
headquarters together with a few
stragglers from other units had now all
arrived in all there seemed to be about
with a half a dozen officers as well as
the Brigadier David and myself there was
Jimmy gray the latter brought news that
the colonel was probably dead although
he could not be sure as they'd become
separated during a scrimmage with an
espy gun of the rest of the officers who
had jumped with the battalion captain
John Simmons the gunner forward observer
was the only left one left continuing
after about 15 minutes a lull in
shooting suggested that I might now be
able to get round to visit the battalion
positions the battalion for the first
time it struck me that I was now in
command of what was left of it pitiful
remnants but they are still fighting the
Brigadier had allotted the south and
west sides of the perimeter to us the
first pit held sergeant whiner with
seven or eight men at the bottom his
eyes shut lay a gray faced and
motionless private Gregory shot through
his stomach
corporal Pritchard had bandaged him up
and give him a shot of morphia but
because his airborne smock had been
pulled down over his blood-stained
dressing to keep as warm as possible he
lay there with no outward sign of injury
looking as a man might do who had
collapsed with exhaustion
Gregory's eyes opened when he saw who
was standing over him he asked for the
favour
his voice was quiet his words measured
incoherent his proposal quite logical
out here without the help of a doctor he
was going to die in any case and he
could stand the pain no longer would
someone please put a bullet through his
head for the moment my grip tightened on
the Mauser in Gregory state I probably
would have been asking for the same
release if it did happen I hope that
someone would have the guts to give it
to me
then I caught winders eye then he knew
that I could not do it
the only way to help Gregory was to give
him a further shot of morphia dangerous
though it would be to do so as I reach
for my own ampule in the breast pocket
of my smock I was ashamed by my
reluctance the reason was purely selfish
sooner or later I might want to use it
on myself wounded and alone behind a
bush with no one about to help me but
sergeant winder came to the rescue
he had scrounged a couple a supply of
ampules from somewhere or another
opening the small black tin he bared
Gregory's arm and pressed the needle
home the words of sympathy and
encouragement sounded pitifully trite as
I pressed Gregory's shoulder nervous of
any reproach which I might see I turned
and walked away without looking at the
wounded man's face
my name was being called it was private
Jones slithering towards me down the
opposite slope of the hollow Jones told
me quickly I was major Unwin killed by a
sniper shot through the forehead as he
was peering over the rim of the hollow
trying to locate the whereabouts of ASP
and no machine gun he had died instantly
Jones was adamant there was no doubt
that he was dead
his brains had been blown out Jones was
urging me to come see his body but I
could not bring myself to do so David
could not be dead it could not have
killed David everyone else yes one after
another friends had died but I never
believed that this could happen in David
so vast so indestructible the humorous
gentle David
the Brigadier was beside me he had also
heard the news for nearly two years he
had known us both and it was plain that
he understood the anguish but there were
other things to think about as we knew
only too well that Brigadier told us our
ammunition was nearly finished and as
our own fire slackened the enemy snipers
were becoming bolder and more men were
being hit soon we would be forced to
surrender so he had decided to take the
initiative we would break out towards
Easter beak charging through the enemy
in solid mass trusting our numbers and
impetus to get through it was an
extraordinary plan for the second time
that day
the Brigadier was ordering us to do what
seemed impossible but our trust in the
brigadiers judgment was now implicit it
was a gamble but one which offered at
least a chance of success to stay here
would only one end one way fifteen
minutes later we were ready it could
have been the start of a race the
Brigadier asked whether we were
then at his shout the hundred of us rose
to our feet and exploded in a solid mass
over the lip of the hollow in front was
the Brigadier himself leading the way
behind came the yelling screaming men
filthy and blood-stained
weapons in their hands bayonets dull and
menacing a fearful sight to anyone in
our path the German fire now seemed to
be coming from every direction but I saw
no one hit we were rushing downhill
along us Alain a solid human battering
ram the first wild plate pace slackened
the firing stopped we had done it we
were through the enemy and out of the
forest for the second time that day
boldness had saved us once again some
default aggressive activity and and I
mean obviously I want to make it clear
that in bullet in both these situations
it wasn't it wasn't a it wasn't a call
of hey there's a there's a there's a
objective we want to reach charge it it
was we can either sit here and do
nothing and die or we can attack that's
that that's the big I don't want anyone
out there thinking okay I'm just gonna
everytime default aggressive I'm gonna
run and we're gonna attack no these are
situations where the alternative to
attacking is is being defensive laying
down and dying and continue to get
picked off and snipers until you get
overrun yeah now they meet up with
finally they they meet up with these
other British troop back to the book
someone was leading us into a garden of
a large house the men dropped to the
ground as they halted conscious that
they were now safe with houses and other
British troops around them others after
a swig from a water bottle lay supine
unconscious in instant sleep I counted
them jimmy gray John Simmons
and Sergeant Winer were there sergeant
major Kelly was missing some
seen him fall in the rush there were
just 49 other men about half from C
company last night there had been 200
the night before 500
now they're in these positions and
they're about to get attacked just below
in the garden but out of sight another
Brent opened up it was Jimmy gray sentry
at the garden gate there was a glimpse
of a camouflaged figure running through
the trees opposite no more than a
hundred yards away diagonally across our
front towards the air landing troops
then a couple more
Jimmy's Bren fired again and one of the
figures pitched forward rolling over
carried on by its own momentum we would
not we would have to fight and this is
there they're talking he's talking about
the fact that they're in the houses now
in these in this village we would have
to fight from the house itself not from
the trenches in the garden it was a
sturdy building with thick solid walls
and in any case the garden was too small
for the purpose from these upper windows
we would have an extra range and
observation to fire diagonally down the
road in front of the houses held by
units to the left and right 15 minutes
later the trim Dutch house had been
wrecked every pane of glass had been
smashed and every picture and mirror
knocked from the walls there was no time
to be careful in the center of each room
barricades had been built well back from
the windows out of sight of the bow but
sighted so that every scrap of ground
outside was covered side boards and
chests of drawers stuffed with books or
bedding made the barricades contents of
the furniture flung in heaps into
corners of the rooms mattresses will
roll down into the basement ready for
use if needed by wounded men more books
crammed into drawers were blocking those
windows not required for shooting
through fortunately the owner of the
house possessed a fine library from its
content seemed he was a doctor with gray
I walked around the house for a final
check before leaving to return to my own
headquarters at the rear Manik vandals
might have swept through it some woman's
life work ruined in the time it took to
drink a cup of coffee
an explosion from above followed by the
clatter of tiles falling from the roof
drowned out the noise from the gun
another bomb burst in the garden just
outside the window sending a couple
fragments whistling into the room now
the Bose were hitting us with mortars as
well
a bullet splintered of the empty frame
behind me and buried itself in the
ceiling a warning that I was far too
close to the back bedroom window there
was a sniper behind us as well as the
spandau a quick movement in the garden
of the house caught my eye then two
figures in the wrong sort of camouflage
darted from behind a bush into the
shelter of a wall they were both not
British so now the enemy was indeed all
around us there was no doubt about it
now John Simmons and his men were in the
houses where they had been left that
morning John had made strong points out
of a couple of houses smaller but just
as robust as the ones held by grey the
two groups had been working closely
together largely I felt certain because
of John's charm of manner and
determination
this young gunner had done very well it
hardly seemed possible that most of his
men hardly knew him by sight yesterday
today he has welded the survivors of
four different companies of a unit in
two of another arm into a tight-knit
entity well capable of carrying on the
fight all day they had held firm killing
and wounding quite a lot of enemy but
losing only one man themselves a
corporal of a company whose hand had
been blown in half by a flying mortar
splinter lined and filthy though his
face was eyes red rimmed and chin
stained with three days worth of fair
fuzzy down John still moved briskly a
reminder to all of us that we could
still keep going so he's got guys that
are stepping up big time inside the
houses we felt reasonably safe from the
shells and bullets but there was always
some cause for the officers and senior
NCOs to move about in the open from one
building to another it was the same as
it had been in the woods the officers
and sergeants stood a straighter greater
chance of being killed or wounded as
their men
all the same it was easier for an
officer with so much to do he had little
time to worry about his own safety also
he always had to try and act the part to
set an example to the others an officer
had to exude confidence however hard it
might be but because he always had to
try to keep a grip on himself it helped
him forget the danger very true very
true got a lot of things on your mind
they get a massive bombardment in these
positions that they're in back to the
book the Germans must be softening us up
in preparation for something more
serious their ammunition seemed
unlimited the bombardment ended quite
suddenly rather as it it started this
would be it nudging Williams to get his
head up from behind the barricade
I shouted a warning to the others Elkins
and Bauer in the next room and the two
signalers who had moved up to the
bedroom at the back the Studdard of the
Bren gun cut across the war the words
Bauer's rifle thudded next door and then
Williams was firing a succession of
bursts from his Bren gun in the orchard
opposite Germans were running through
the trees towards us several dropped
this could only be the start of an
attack now from either flank the sound
of rifles and machineguns reached us
accompanied by the thud of exploding
grenades the attack was coming in all
along our front some of the Germans
among the fruit trees were firing back a
couple of rifle bullets splintered the
front of the Wardrobe
then more gray figures were lumbering
towards us through the trees some fell
others ducked behind the puny trees they
didn't stand a chance it was like
shooting targets on the practice range
the Germans and the mortars had been
forced to stop because their troops were
so close it was so it was it was
possible to fire slow carefully aimed
shots with little or no distraction the
only way out of the orchard was through
the single gap in the high fence but the
enemy soldiers never got within 20 yards
of it at all German officer was standing
in the middle of the drive out in the
open clear of the trees waving his arms
to the men behind him no more than fifty
yards away every detail of his face and
uniform was clearly visible he was a
handsome young man fair-haired and
smartly turned out already he'd been
standing there for about five seconds
encouraging his men to advance as I
leveled my sights on the German officer
I knew that I was looking at someone who
is just about to die it seemed a pity he
was such a courageous boy just the sort
just the sort one would like to have had
as a platoon commander my finger started
to squeeze the trigger but it was too
late someone else had fired the German
fell spread-eagled and lay still at
least he died quickly the death of the
young officer marked the end of the
attack now no one moved in the orchard
except for a single wounded man
squirming his way back through the trees
so it's interesting when you you take
the leader and the leader goes down and
the attacks over now also it's important
to note that although the leader stood
up and encouraged the attack by taking
that risk of being out there in front of
everyone in this case it didn't work out
well because he got shot killed and the
attack faltered perhaps if he could have
found a little bit better of a position
to do that from then then maybe then
maybe he would have been able to
encourage his troops and stay alive hmm
back to the book but we had one no more
than a temporary respite 15 minutes
later we could hear the unnerving noise
once again tracks were clattering
towards us so I haven't I don't know why
I haven't talked about this yet but you
had
of these airborne troops on the ground
and their biggest fear is tanks and
you've heard me talk many times about my
love for tanks and how effective and
awesome
they are as tools and as weapons and the
way that the tankers utilize them
they're just they're just awesome
machines mm-hmm but here you have the
table's turned and and the good guys
don't have real any effective way of
stopping these tanks you can shoot a
machine gun all day long at a Panzer
tank and it's not gonna do a damn thing
hmm and so it can just and by the way
you hide in a building cool a tank will
go right through a building they go
right through buildings they will go
right through a building like it looks
like a construction piece of heavy
equipment that's what it looks like
it'll go right through a building like
it's nothing so these guys are
absolutely horrified of the tank showing
up that's their fear tram tracks were
clattering toward us a gun footed and
the dark red house opposite began to
fall apart rat as round after round
crashed into it
muzzle flashes from the far side of the
orchard revealed the position of the
attacker but there was nothing we could
do at least the men were not waiting in
the house but slipping one after another
out the door back across the road
through the headquarter house on either
side the guns were firing now it was our
turn
the the tank wrecks some of the houses
and then it the tank leaves so here we
go it's it was time to strike back the
tanks had gone and as yet the Bose did
not appear to have occupied the houses
lying out there in the rear gardens
overlooked from the windows we were
vulnerable indeed
soon the mortaring would start again
then we would be safer back in the
ruined buildings as John Simmons
listened to the instructions the young
captain's manner was as relaxed as ever
calm and outwardly self-confident he
somehow managed to give the impression
that he was almost enjoying the
morning's work possibly he was making
that a point
subconsciously perhaps that a gunner
could always take charge of 30
infantrymen but there were undoubtedly
immense reserves of strength hidden
behind that cool exterior as he lay
behind the bed of half-dead pea plants
scanning the houses for any sign of
German occupants there was no trace of
disquiet in his voice as he discussed
his orders to counter-attack and clear
the street of the enemy 15 minutes after
John had gone I was still in the same
place in the vegetable patch watching
the second hand of my watch creep
towards the top of the dial then Gray's
weapon opened up on the right firing
back in the back into the rooms of the
houses more in the hope of distracting
the enemy than providing covering fire
the danger to John's men lay on the
other side the front of the houses now
John's three Bren guns were firing as
well on the left
the assault party would soon be moving
into the street it came the sustained
rattle of a Spandau gun first one then a
second after that there was silence
except for one or two rifle shots
I waited lying in the vegetable patch
almost distraught with worry
something was badly wrong nothing could
be seen from here but I had to resist
the temptation of going to find out for
myself what had happened
I must avoid getting involved in the
skirmish then corporal day now John's
second-in-command was running through
the flowerbeds toward me dazed face said
everything even before he started to
speak the attack had failed it had
failed the moment John had been killed
out there in the middle of the street
and ten yards in front of de and the
rest of the assault party John had died
in just the same way as that young
German officer this morning that had
finished it the rest of them including
day had turned and run but in some
extraordinary way no one else had been
hit day made no excuse no attempt to
excuse himself telling the story
factually and not trying to put a gloss
on the incident the implication was
clear they had been asked to do too much
so now I had been responsible for
killing John as well it had been so
simple I had issued the orders and then
John had walked out into the middle of
that road to be shot down by the
machine-gun I should not have done it
the counter-attack should never have
been attempted
the men were no longer capable of making
such an effort they could still hang on
to their positions fighting from behind
cover but after six days of continuous
battle they lacked the will to get to
their feet and go for the enemy in the
woods it had just been possible to urge
them forward in one last surge of
willpower but since then they did endure
a further 48 hours of death starvation
thirst and fatigue and in the woods it
was men from my own company today it had
been different today a mixture of men
survivors of four different companies
had been
left to follow a gunner officer whom
they hardly knew there was a limit to
what soldiers could be asked to do and I
had gone beyond those limits and so John
Simmons had died
[Music]
that's the burden of command
back to the book it was impossible to
understand why the Germans were not
using their armor to support this
infiltration by their infantry if they
had done so all resistance would have
collapsed long ago and the tanks would
have been on the lawns the crushing news
that the Brigadier had been badly
wounded came through on the telephone
just before the line went dead once
again the Boetsch were now among the
houses and gardens which the glider
pilots had been holding and gray had
reported that he was being shot at from
two sides at the same time the
quartermaster had also sent word that
the enemy were behind him and that he
had long ago lost all contact with the
recce on his left
they are just in a wretched state and he
goes to meet with the colonel in one of
the buildings
the Colonel's seem to be trying to break
something to to us gently and then it
came out it was hard to believe harder
still to understand the division was to
be withdrawn over the Rhine that night
it was all over it had been it had only
been possible to ferry about two hundred
and fifty men of the Dorset's over the
river before dawn a profitless addition
to the perimeter garrison the Second
Army had overreached itself in trying to
get to us and although the troops were
pouring northward they lacked the
strength across the river and continued
the advance into Germany already the
boats were hammering from the flanks at
their narrow lines of communication so
the operation had failed everything had
been in vain it was all a waste
listening to the outline of what had to
be done that night it was hard to
concentrate on the details the first
emotion was grief and then utter
disappointment the battalion had been
destroyed to no purpose
and that's it they get the order that
night to leave and they come up with a
plan they actually follow rope
they put rope at night down towards the
river where they're gonna get extracted
and at night they attempt to follow that
rope down there and of course along the
way they lose more men men get separated
men don't hang on they get lost and they
lose even more men as they're trying to
make it to their extraction point but he
does get end up with a small group of
people at this extraction point there's
Canadian boats there to bring them
across the Rhine River back to the book
the Canadians were already pulling the
last men into the boat and I was
standing with Harrison alone in the
river when I heard a whiners voice
harshly insisting that no one would be
left behind the young Coxon needed no
further urging but importers to be
careful as the boat was grossly
overloaded then Harrison pushed me up
over the side and the two of us flopped
down behind the Coxon as the engine went
into gear and the boat moved towards the
midstream so now they get across the
river they get dropped off and and to
answer your question earlier once they
get dropped off on there on the other
side of the there on the western side of
the Rhine River it's basically secure
area mm-hmm
even though it was only you know several
hundred yards away it was relatively
secure and now what they have to do is
they have to march back about five miles
to get to a even more secure base here
we go back to the book as we reached the
track which after a few hundred yards
led us to the road when I stopped the
men flopped to the ground empty and
lifeless lacking any wish to go on more
parties of men appeared through the
darkness shambling in the exhaustion of
relief all terror ended devoid of the
willpower needed to summon up further
effort there was only one way to make
the two-mile March bearable an
old-fashioned remedy I called the
sergeant whiner to fall the men in
three's the discipline bark bounced back
to me as whiner pulled himself to his
feet shouting to the men to fall in
there is no trace of query or surprise
in whiners voice and the men shuffled to
their feet that's that's your root
training right there that you're
exhausted after eight days of continuous
combat you're just done and the sergeant
says all right on your feet form a
column of threes and you do it there get
close to the end I'm now that can see
the camp mmm and I halted them there was
only one way to end such a March it was
pointless perhaps but I decided to make
the final gesture bringing them to
attention I ordered them to slope arms
and to march by the left to attention
I sensed their appreciation as their
shoulders went back this was the way
they always returned to camp this was
the way they always finished as they
stepped off for the last 50 yards they
were even swinging their arms so they
marched back into this camp once they
get into this camp they get loaded up
into a vehicle a big military transport
vehicle that's going to take them
further to the rear where they can get
some treatment and they're loaded into
that vehicle and here we go back to the
book the canopy of the truck now
sheltered us but my shivering became
uncontrollable I knew I was becoming
lightheaded and could hear myself
grieving aloud for those that we had
left behind particularly for those who
had been lost during the withdrawal down
the riverbank there was silence in the
truck then I heard as if from a long way
off the voice of Sergeant whiner
calm and flat saying that none of them
would have got back if it had not been
for me it was true to say that I would
never have got back if it hadn't been
for them but I shall always be grateful
to whiner for having said it
the next thing I remember was Winer
and Harrison half carrying me into what
seemed to be a hospital someone was
stripping off my clothes and dressing me
in pajamas then I felt the prick of a
needle in my arm I was awake the sun
shining into the windows of the ward in
orderly brought tea and food on a tray i
lay between the clean sheets looking at
the torn and filthy garments on the
chair by the side of the bed there was
nothing wrong with me now
I saw that my hand was wrapped in a
clean bandage when the nursing orderly
came to remove the tray he brought me
the message that a soldier was waiting
in the corridor to see me as soon as the
orderly left the room I slipped out of
bed and put on my clothes and went out
into the corridor waiting there was
Harrison a broad smile on his face
telling me that captain gray and mr.
Elkins and turned up with eight of the
missing men another twenty stragglers
had also arrived from somewhere or
another but that was a lot that was the
battalion three officers and 43 soldiers
we walked out the door of the hospital
side side by side the week September Sun
shone down on the battered buildings
away in the distance the dull rumble of
the battle still rolled down from the
north
[Music]
and once all the men were recovered and
that's that's the end of the book and
when all the men were recovered it and
when you look at the actual battalion of
the hundred and 56th parish parachute
battalion they look like this three
hundred and thirteen men were captured
many of those who were wounded there was
98 killed in action and there was a
total of 68 from the battalion that made
it across the Rhine safely and those 68
men if they could heal up were then sent
to the other battalions inside the first
pair of burgade and the hundred and 56th
parachute battalion was actually
disbanded it ceased to exist Jeffrey
Powell went on to retire from the Army
the British Army in 1964 he retired as a
major-general he was awarded the
Military Cross which is Britain's third
highest award for valor and this is what
his citation reads at Arnhem after his
commanding officer had become a casualty
major Powell took command of the
remnants of the battalion up to this
time he'd conducted himself with the
greatest gallantry for the remaining six
days he retained control of his unit and
also of the men of other units in the
area under the most difficult conditions
heavy fire for mortars artillery and
self-propelled guns never stopped his
activity in getting round his section of
the perimeter and encouraging his men to
greater efforts throughout the whole
period of the arnhem battle in spite of
being wounded this officer showed
himself to be a gallant leader of men
and a most capable fighter and one whose
bravery was a source of inspiration to
the men under his command and to all
those around him
[Music]
and I think it's pretty clear that if
you read a book like this general Powell
is still a source of inspiration as are
the rest of these incredibly brave men
and also a source of leadership lessons
of what to do and what not to do and
it's also an incredible reminder of that
heavy burden of command and the fact of
the matter is when you lead you own
every decision and every action not only
of yourself but of your men and with
that burden you owe it to them to be as
well prepared to be as tactically sound
and to be as physically and mentally
strong as you can possibly be and that
goes for any leadership position when
you are a leader be as prepared as you
possibly can and then you go out and you
lead and you lead with courage and you
lead with resolution and you lead with
boldness
boldness like Jeffrey Powell then the
officers and the men of the hundred and
fifty sixth parachute battalion pretty
amazing book that you know like I said I
got this book six days ago or something
somebody just sent it to me and I gave
it the the little tests when I kind of
open books up because people send me a
lot of books sure and I gave it the I
gave it the test you know I open up I
read a couple sections and it
immediately you know I'll give off all
open to a book in four or five different
places to see what it reads like and
this you know within the first page the
first page that I read I said oh we it
looks like we have a winner here this
one's gonna be on the podcast because
it's just impactful and the account now
the in the back of the book he talks
about the the individuals in it just
read some of them off here the Brigadier
was General John Hackett the colonel was
Dickey DeVoe of the Grenadier Guards his
fellow Grenadier was Sergeant mater did
sergeant major Dennis gay his Batman the
guy that he talks about Harrison
throughout the book the guy that's there
from the beginning to the end always by
his side that was actually a guy named
Fred Tracy hmm look I named David &
Unwin in the book is the character in
the book the real guy was named Michael
Page who had been Powell's best man and
whose son Jeffrey born posthumously had
another son named Michael
in Luke Tyler and Sergeant whiner and
Jones and Johnson as these were all real
people so you know this is another guy
that very similar to Major John Glover
who said he had a hard time writing
about himself in the first person you
know I did this and I did that that's
the same thing that Powell said he had a
hard time writing until he just made it
about some other he put made some other
character in his hand and you know from
that perspective
man you definitely this book I like I
said I read I don't know 5% of it it's
not a huge book though actually it's
only a couple hundred pages long
and it's a very fast read did you find
it to give you this weird stressful
feeling reading though absolutely like
listening to is like just I would I was
debating when to tell you and when to
tell everyone that that this is not a
good that this isn't a good story right
that this isn't a positive thing mm-hmm
and I kind of just I don't know when I
actually said that hey they're not gonna
win I mean I said that the the operation
Market Garden was it was a failure but
you know what does that really look like
you know yeah like you don't know what
that looks like until you get reading
this book and then you start to feel
what it feels like and absolutely and
and when you read the whole book man it
is just coming apart it's just the
little misfortune little miss for and
they're just coming and they don't stop
they just don't stop mm-hmm it's a it's
a nightmare scenario and yeah and
there's tons of great lessons Lawrence
it's so it's so amazing because I never
read this book before I just got yeah
but it's amazing cover move yeah
decentralized command yeah even
prioritize and execute even at that part
when you're keeping it simple write
everything that that we learned the you
know I should have learned this years
ago mm-hmm and when I think about you
know I was you you look back at your
life right and you said yourself what
could I have done better what could I do
different and you know everyone in the
SEAL Teams like basically you get one
shot at each job other than just being a
a shooter and a platoon that you can do
three or four times if you're lucky but
then once you get into a leadership
position you're like you're an assistant
platoon commander you do that one time
then you're a platoon commander you do
that one time then you're tasking a
commander you do that one time generally
some kind of sometimes did guys do
rarely
guys do more than one of those same
thing on the enlisted side guy gets to
do a leading petty officer does that one
time chief petty officer of a platoon
platoon chief does that one time senior
chief in charge of a task unit does that
one time you don't get to repeat the
jobs and so basically when you're
finally getting good at your job you're
done and now you got to go get the next
job up the chain of command so for me it
was always and now looking back and even
talking to talking to my seal buddies
now like like how can we prepare them
better so that they know what we had to
learn during the job it's it's it's a
hard thing to do because it's because a
lot of stuff you actually have to learn
from experience yeah and and actually we
talked about that at the last muster
which is that was a big part that we
talked about your if you're gonna get
good at something you have two choices
experience or training and training is a
way to condense experience down and
distill it and that's what was great
about one way and when I was running
training on the West Coast we we got to
really condense that experience I mean
guys went through guys went through
hellacious training and where we provide
total chaos for them that most guys
wouldn't experience that kind of chaos
in their whole career or in ten careers
but they would get it and they would get
pushed through for heart so that when
when they got out on the battlefield
they were ready for the for the chaos I
was out there because we entrained him
and we pushed them further and harder
during training then we hoped they would
get pushed on the battlefield mmm yeah
it's crazy even that cover and move even
when they're retreating
it's like it showed like how you got to
keep that yes that discipline with that
discipline it's kind of like you know
like in an MMA fight or something and
the guy starts getting hit on the inside
and rather than still covering up a
little bit while he goes back he like
runs away or turns his back
yeah you know on your back yes
sorry Zack and you're done but great
book I definitely recommend it for your
reading list yeah there was that part in
there that the guy came up to I think
reload ammo or something and the guys
sitting there yeah so he gets like
scolded or whatever you know it turns
out he's wounded like that's kind of
that was an interesting little lesson
there like you just don't know so you
can't just start going off totally true
and and I don't know if you remember
somebody asked us a question one time
about you know how do i these people
that have had everything given to them
yeah and I and I you know I've had a
ride I grew up in a tough neighborhood
like are you you you actually don't know
what the ice has been through yeah and
we had that whole discussion yeah that's
the same thing true on a day-to-day
basis with every other human being that
you're dealing with you don't know what
they're going through you don't know
what triumphs and tragedies they've had
in their life you don't know what just
happened to them this morning so the
recommended course of action is you you
give someone a little bit of slack you
don't know you know yeah you ever seen
that that Seinfeld when you go he goes
to talk to that girl come on from
actually pretty much this but just on
Seinfeld so he goes to talk to this
grace I gotta talk to that girl she's
hot or whatever he goes up to anything
he's like hey hey hello excuse me and
her back is kind of turned you know he's
like excuse me hello hello like idiot
and he starts to get real mad that she's
not listening to him finally he walks
like more close to her and she kind of
starts to turn around he's like oh so
now you pay attention what are you deaf
and she's like bingo like signs to him
oh yeah you know you got a chill yeah
find out about people first a free start
make sure you make sure the regimental
sergeant major isn't wounded in both
legs before you start dressing him down
I know that's that's like that's a good
thing he put that in this book you know
that's pretty humble yeah for him to put
this in this book I mean yeah and that
other part where there were all what
like tired and stuff right or they were
defeated essentially they were actually
you mean when they were basically broken
men
yeah and then they and they got up and
they just started charging getting yeah
default aggress yeah yeah default
aggressive part that's like like you
know why there's big centipedes no no
they're bigger than like centipedes that
I've seen here okay give me a figure
like six inches twelve like it's six is
like a normal big centipede inches and
they still get bigger anyway there I
mean compared to you you know that
they're they're little bugs they're
little right whatever and you just step
on it but like when you start messing
with it and it starts to get nuts a
super intimidation oh but they can chase
you out of your room you got chased out
of your room by anything like even like
a what like a wasp or you don't like
with these little things that are way
smaller than you so and they just get
nuts and then and like you don't want to
mess with it you know so life life was
over my houses a while ago couple years
ago and there was a lizard in my house
like about a yes he thought a 9 inch
lizard and so my son and Lafe are going
to try and catch this lizard and and
their being weak wait wait no get a box
on it and also so I come in mr. tough
guy you know I come in reached I go just
grab that thing you will seize reach
down I'd reached down to grab this thing
this thing turns its head and bites yeah
and I screamed like like the Jim Carrey
like ah yeah and I flicked my hand it
was it was absolutely hilarious because
I learned from being a big tough guy to
screaming oh and having a lizard bit
onto my finger Jud by the way this thing
drew blood yeah on my thumb so yeah I
was default aggressive but it didn't
work out the lizard was more default
aggressive than I was yeah see in the
end that is funny that's a funny story
for a couple of reasons in my opinion
but that is the exact same concept
though you know where if you woulda
liked how you said in the book just kept
your head you smash that
well if I wanted to catch it alive I
wasn't trying to kill it yeah but still
I should have been more great like the
bite didn't even hurt right
I just shocked me yeah yeah I wasn't
ready for the gnashing of the teeth
yeah those lizards we have a lot of
those especially when he gets hot those
I mean I'm assuming it's the same time
they're these but here's the thing
growing up on Kauai there's these thing
they call them we call them chameleons
but they're like a knoll and only a mmm
oh le that's what you spent spell it
they turn green or brown or whatever and
they get they get pretty big and they're
super aggressive like when you grab them
oh that's the first lift red thing comes
out of their neck and they start biting
it and you get them to when you hold
them after a while they start to calm
down yeah I think they just start to get
sick and stuff I don't know I don't know
but they calm down so you can do this
thing where basically I can't fee if you
have a lizard's head you go like this
and he'll go like that he'll try to bite
you so what you do is when he calms down
a little whatever and when you grab him
he's trying to kill you but when he
calms down after I don't know three four
minutes you do that and he'll kill keep
kind of like he'll do it less and less
and less and less he'll always do that
though it'll just be a lot less
aggressive and then if you put your
finger in his mouth he'll bite you and
he won't let go so you got to kind of
drag your finger out and yet it'll it
can cause blood or whatever but what we
do is and you can see pictures of this
we do that and we put it on put the
lizard on our ears so the lizard would
be an earring an earring yeah biting
areas you'd have two lizards hanging
down but anyway the point there being
[Music]
fun if you can keep your yeah you know
yeah when you grow up with that stuff
like those lizards are not scary even if
they're aggressive and some of them they
get pretty like big and bulky and
they're like dang this thing it has some
power to it this little lizard you know
and but even here I wanted I grabbed
them they're like no I wouldn't scream
like you yeah I say any experiences
got me dude it was awful it was awful
well being prepared I guess is what
we're talking about the aggressive won't
you get default aggressive with letting
anybody know if they want to support
this broadcast maybe how they could do
it also support chuckles traumatising
experience with lizards lizards by
fingers and him screaming was it life in
him it was late in my son yeah did they
lose respect for you that well as
actually funny cuz life always talks
about you know me being calm and that's
why he laughed so hard we we were
driving one time and we almost got in a
car wreck he was driving actually and
I'll have him tell the story but we hit
mud and we hit we were out in the desert
we're going for 65 miles an hour on a
back road backed by all these farms and
it was two o'clock in the morning three
o'clock in the morning something like
that and normally these roads are
completely dry they're in the desert and
we're hauling & Lace driving I think he
drive his truck
yeah he was driving his truck we're
hauling and all of a sudden out of
nowhere we see we see a big 18-wheeler
on the side of the road on the opposite
side road but it did a narrow road yeah
and as we're hauling all of a sudden we
hit a water like water probably a couple
inches deep of water and mud because
it's a year what happened somewhere
irrigation from all this farmland had
broken and there was this flood and so
we hit this thing and we're immediately
hydroplane and and Lafe is from Texas
Lafe is from Texas so he's not used to
driving in the snow I grew up driving in
the snow in New England you know you
just you just deal with it everyone's
like a rally driver up there yeah and so
and so Lafe he he's not really used to
this and he starts to oversteer the car
which is really really bad yeah and you
know I'm sitting there and we're going
65 miles an hour he's funny but he tells
the story - he's like we've we thought
we're gonna die it's not exact we were
definitely not yeah and I'm sitting
there in the passenger seat and I say up
don't oversteer
don't overstep no brakes no brakes
alright you're good because that's the
other thing mistake you can make if you
jam on the brakes yeah you're gonna lock
it up and you're gonna slide you're
going
lose control so I just know don't
oversteer don't over steer no brakes no
brakes all right you're good so that was
not my reaction when I got down the
phone by the lizard good but hey man you
know if you want to support this spot
guess how about let's talk about that
possible do it so one good way and
support this is what it is origin right
origin the brand origin main comm that's
a website they've got a lot of cool
stuff one of the cool items actually
there's a bunch are geese for jiu-jitsu
I remember back when um kind of won't be
first started this thing mmm that's that
would be the main question about
jiu-jitsu what kind of yeah and I'd be
like oh yeah there's these and I give
them the the three they talk actually
there was there's four of them and it
was shortly after where you recommended
this these origin ones and then when I
went there I was like oh shoot this it's
kind of expensive I don't know you know
but then I just looked at the one that
was like it was like the first one I saw
but there are many varying prices of
geese and they're all good by the way
I know this because I have some
nonetheless if you're still wondering
what kind of ghee to get origin you 100%
you have options you know as far as
pricing and stuff like that if you want
the deluxe one versus the more basic one
but they're all dope and here's the
thing about them they're all made in
America and not in the sense where
they're just kind of assembled in
America but sort of the other materials
are sourced somewhere else the materials
are sourced would you call them sourced
it's the wrong with the raw material it
comes from here America I know that
burka
boom brought over the main assembled
yeah that's not appropriate
yeah woven on a loom boom into this
outstanding material moist
what do you call it wicking William
right that's when it kind of like helps
ya with moisture yeah I didn't know all
this by the way I'm like being educated
on it and there's lots I know by the way
um and I antimicrobial that's a big deal
anyway or Janine dot-com that's where
you get school stuff there's other stuff
too like rash guards and even like
clothes regular clothes athletic wear
it's dope all meet America in America
boom also for some legitimate fitness
gear on it calm slash jackal I just got
the I know I'm into kettlebells I know I
said that before him say it again
what is yours what is your heaviest
kettlebell alone you have 40 kilograms
right so it's 88 knots
mine's 90 by the way I have to do yeah
well I guess you know it's clear what I
got to do maybe I'll get another one
stir it up but um shoot who was I
talking to about it
oh yeah Morgan you know more yeah we're
talking we were talking about kettle
bell Vincent Morgan is feeling strong I
told him that yesterday yeah not not
just because that's it's kind of a
insult in jujitsu yes right yeah like
hey you feel really strong it's an
insult yeah I made it perfectly clear
yesterday I was like hey you feel
jiu-jitsu strong I said it's not I'm not
trying to say you feel strong like hey
you're a meat you're a meathead right
but you feel strong in a positive way
because and I said here's the deal if it
was just you being strong then five
years ago when I started training I was
like oh you feel strong I didn't say it
then cuz didn't feel strong you feel
strong now that your juice is getting
yeah be there better and and you're
getting more skills well yeah I feel
like we got to come up with a different
expression or maybe just a modified
expression because some people yeah like
they'll people tell me I'm strong or
whatever and after a while I was like we
I felt the same thing that you yeah one
time I told you like you're strong I
thought it was kind of maybe
subconsciously I thought it was kind of
established that okay look you're really
good at jujitsu you know I thought that
was kind of a gay
so if I were to tell you you're strong
and be kind of like I like everybody
yeah was I like oh yeah I was like we're
like right on my technique yours like no
my technique I was like yeah no no I
know that I know your technique is
outstanding yeah a little bit
not in angry we're nothing like that but
yeah and funny actually
I'm surprised I wasn't a little bit more
sarcastic about it
CLK and which you know I'm surprised I
didn't say yeah I'm glad I'm so strong
yeah that I can just you know what I'm
sure people say it and I know people
don't mean it I know they don't mean
that you know what what how we take it
and kind of like you're strong yeah it's
your physical strength not your jujitsu
technique that's what we take it as and
they're just throwing it in like how I
essentially how I did with you is kind
of like look you're better than you did
to than me you you beat me up all the
time but in the ocean top of that you're
pretty strong yeah that's probably what
people are saying most of the time but
so when people be like dang you're
strong you're great in you and when they
say you're strong I say yeah I lift a
lot of weights yeah so it kind of gives
them the impression kind of like yeah my
weight lifting basically beats your
jujitsu kind of thing and that's the
more of an insult you know kind of thing
brother it's it's a joke really yeah
nonetheless so yes Morgan he's strong
jujitsu strong technique you so that
means if the technique is getting better
and it reveals right it can deliver the
strength in the proper way
yeah yes good job Morgan but we're
talking about kettlebells yeah he was
like broke attaboy it so hard so I
started to feel kind of good because I
got this 90-pound one and I was like I
lifted it up and you know okay you know
this the one hand boom clean would be
clean press is there if you use your
legs if you use your legs to snap it up
there a little bit that is the
clean-and-jerk okay even one if you just
do if you don't use any legs and you
just power it up smoothly that's a press
okay so mine is clean and jerk I just
use the whole kind of body or whatever
so my met cons they do when I got the
werewolf ones those are like 62 pounds I
do two at a time boom boom okay easy
and you do reps you know it's all a
thing so I got this the gorillas 172
pounds and I could do that one just as
you get strong you know so get the 90
power
I'm like I only got one too so I don't
know do you think - at one time is
easier because of the balance right no
it's not easier just I mean you're using
more energy for sure but as far as like
doing the ballot you know yeah okay well
so one is easier doing one is for sure
okay good well okay
gotcha so I got one Bigfoot that's 90
pounds and I lifted that up I think man
I'm not and so it was like maybe two
three days later I was like well I gotta
try that's the only you know I got the
72 pound one I can do that you know a
bunch of times actually but so I just
warmed up a bunch and just first time I
did it like I straight up failed I
couldn't do it and I was like alright
alright now I know how it feels now and
all this stuff and then then I could do
it boom both so you're good I'd go yeah
that's good solid glad we all know that
now yep that's relevant just actually
which is actually what makes kettle
bells kind of fun to do is because it
does require legitimate technique yeah
like you can't J like it's hard it it's
like a dumbbell or a barbell or a
machine well if you're doing barbell
snatches it takes a hell yeah and that's
really the spectrum you know so if you
go laughter you pedal bone and dumb cuz
dumbbells are straight-up balanced I
mean they're not they're not like a
print but they have a handle both sides
of the handle equal amount of weight you
know boom you just have to balance your
body and then after you get that balance
down that's pretty easy barbell even
less cuz you don't have two sides got to
be balanced it's just one long thing and
then two sides of that is balance then
you go machine you don't even need
balance you just need the strength to
push so it's that spectrum so the
kettlebell it's way on this side of the
spectrum where it kind of there's the
game within the game you know that's
what makes them more fun I think you see
progress in both areas technique and
strength anyway we leave it at that
if you want the cool kettle bells on it
dot-com
slash choco or jump ropes battle maces
the way do you call them battle maces or
just maces phasers yeah those were clubs
yeah though you can get some cool
workouts with that and they do like your
forearms get
I didn't look into like what exactly you
know they're gonna improve but I know
core strength and all this stuff but
there's all these little things they
improve to outstanding stuff also good
way to support if you're gonna get this
book men at how do you how do you
pronounce the name
Arden him or aren't him yeah barking men
aren't him Jeffrey Powell that's how I
good amounts to do anyways I'm apologize
to anyone that's from Holland
yeah and pronounces it a different way I
looked at it on YouTube and how they
said it and it was like they say oh how
to pronounce our name and there's
fourteen different ways to say it yeah I
just rolled the dice and picked one that
sounded easiest for me to say so sorry
if I'm saying it wrong no good but if
you want to get that book or any other
book that chuckle reviews on the website
just go to jucco podcast.com on the top
menu there click on books from episodes
all the books are listed there by
episode along with the few other things
but mainly just the books from from by
episode you click through there boom
takes you to Amazon get those books
there that's a good way to support
that's the Amazon click through or if
you do any other shopping your beginning
a tripod or a video camera or duct tape
whatever click through there boom that's
a good way to support great way to
support also a little addition there you
know how we had the website Chaco
podcast to.com that's oh there's a long
story I think I went into it it was like
when I was like testing like what
website provider whatever I was like let
me get this one because what if I'm
attached it it's a long story and then
so we ended up getting jock podcast calm
and they're both kind of there but jock
podcast too is kind of the primary one
mm-hmm it's not the primary one anymore
Jaakko podcast it's jockle podcast calm
okay so that's the website and that was
actually a trooper that straight-up
goddess chocolate poun yeah yeah looking
out for is in and that's a big deal of
some in New York good dude yeah that's a
huge deal because um like
do you have your own name yeah okay so
people will be like oh this guy's
blowing up he'll they'll go and they'll
buy the domain name either hold on to it
or immediately go to you and be like hey
you want to buy this for me
maybe yeah they'd hold it hostage in
fact I think there might be like legal
like defense against it like if someone
gets your name or your your kid's name
and you're kind of a public figure I
think I'm not sure but yeah that's what
people do man or they'll buy a bunch of
domain names that sound cool
yeah they'll be like yeah you can buy
this from me kind of thing it's it's
super wack when they do with like euro
you know when they know like that's your
community UFC had for a long time they I
don't know what they paid for eventually
paid for UFC calm but for a long time
they were like UFC dot TV and all the
energy but they had to step up I bet you
they I bet somebody made a lot of money
off that one yeah there's three letters
yes like if you get the less letter
that's more money crazytown nonetheless
but yeah chuckle about caste calm that's
the main website now if you were going
to jockle podcast - dot-com it's it's
not that anymore doesn't send you though
over it it does did but well while I'm
switching I'm doing this thing they will
eventually you will eventually yes but
if you run into that that's why God will
have been hitting me up and rightly so
thanks for that
so yeah nonetheless back to the point if
you want to support and by giving these
books go through the website and click
through there it's a good way to support
small action huge reaction small huge
that's how it works also subscribe to
the podcast iTunes if you haven't
already stitcher if you don't use i/os
iPhone Google Play any anywhere they
will where they provide podcasts boom
we're on there so subscribe that's a
good way also YouTube yes I put some
excerpts on there more excerpts and I
continue to do so shareable excerpts try
to keep them under four minutes that's
cool right for ya might be a little long
but every once in a while you get it
like a good like 10 minute one letter
thing yeah but they're more [__] better
than to us a long think about what the
videos that you you want to get
compression yeah and its former
tops yeah and it depends on the do you
you should edit them maybe like make him
shorter yeah yeah I mean if it's
appropriate because sometimes you don't
wanna sometimes it's just you saying
like a whole thing and it's like okay
that's solid and sometimes it's you and
then my rebuttal to kind of kind of
bolster the point your point because
you'll clarify it because I you know and
it's all it's it makes sense so
sometimes if you edit certain things out
maybe the message isn't there as much as
we should be not all the time not all
the time but most of time nonetheless
I'll look into it about that ideally if
a video and this goes along with like
people's typically attention span should
be what like about a minute and a half I
don't know but my attention spans
getting tested right now by supports
just saying we this is important stuff
we need to go over this so we can come
to the best conclusion on how to conduct
ourselves in regards to YouTube excerpts
and other things nonetheless subscribe
to youtube channel it's good we're gonna
provide value how about that no oh
you're into the video version because
some people are some people are into
more the video version of the podcast
yeah you know boom subscribe if you
haven't already YouTube also Chaco has a
store it's called Jaco store chuckles
Derek um if you didn't already know on
there we got some cool stuff shirts
mainly some rash guards I just made in
order for hoodies thicker heavier fall
is coming are we in fall right now fall
is the first day of fall is like the
other day we are in fall yeah so we got
some not that we're doing a whole
seasonal thing I'm just saying it's fall
now getting cool eating cooler check got
some hoodies on there got some shirts on
there got some rash guards on there I
think I'm gonna do a warrior kid rash
guard mmm
I have one yeah I know it's like it's
not in production yet yeah and it's not
I'm gonna change it a little bit some
coloring stuff and whatever but it is
pretty cool
good good little pre response also hats
on there and some other cool stuff I'm
not saying get something I'm saying go
on there check it out if you want to
support and you want to get something
you think something is cool
for yourself or for your you know friend
wife girlfriend neighbor whoever didn't
get something good way to support
actually great way to support also
psychological warfare okay what
psychological warfare is if you don't
know it's an album with Chaco tracks so
basically if you're on your campaign
against weakness and you have a moment
of weakness this is like a little spot
so basically you put on these audio
tracks to let you know hey pragmatically
don't skip this workout today
hey don't slip on this diet today hey
your procrastination isn't working and
here's why but it's jockle telling you
so it's kind of like more effective way
more effective percent success rate in
my experience 100% that's legit
they also Jaco whitey if you want it you
can get that on Amazon it tastes good
and it makes you feel good also on
Origin main calm you can get Jaco super
krill krill oil that will make you feel
good and on top of that you can get
Jaco joint warfare which is awesome
what's in that by the way its
glucosamine chondroitin goes the main
the main but then we put some additional
things in there yeah and it's it's been
rocking it it's a it's it's awesome
you've got books or I've got some books
if you want to read them one is called
way the warrior kid one is called
extreme ownership the warrior kid book
is for kids extreme ownership is for
people in leadership positions or people
that want to be in leadership positions
there's also a new book coming out
called discipline equals freedom Field
Manual it actually comes out October
17th and at one point many months ago
October 17th seemed like it was a long
ways away but it's not
more it's here so you can order that one
it is unlike any book that you have ever
seen or read also what's interesting
about this book is people keep asking me
if it's gonna be on audible it's not
gonna be on audible instead of being on
audible it is gonna be on iTunes it's
gonna be on Amazon mp3 it's gonna be on
Google Play it's gonna be where you can
find mp3 tracks there's a reason for
this if you do it through audible you'll
get this one big long book and it's in
what the book is the way the book is
written it's written to be chunked up
and you're gonna want to take parts of
it and play it at certain times more
like you would do with the psychological
warfare album so people are asking for
more psychological warfare that's what
we're doing just gonna cause freedom
field man you know it's gonna be
available as an album that you can buy
and then you can do what you want with
the tracks you can make them your alarm
ringtone you can listen to them out of
order in any order you can put them in a
mixed you can do a lot more stuff with
them that's why we're doing it as an
album with tracks instead of as an
audible book so you know what we might
you know people might have a little
challenge finding it or realizing you
know when they go on to Amazon or they
go on to Barnes & Noble they won't see
that it's available they'll be looking
for the audible and you won't be able to
find it I'm sorry well just inaudible I
think that's why they won't listen
you'll be able to find it in the audible
platform right or not be but it'll be on
Amazon it'll be on Amazon but you I
don't think it'll be linked in so you
the same thing where you go oh here it
is I didn't see it and it's gonna be
hard to find kind of like it's hard to
find on iTunes it started to find
psychological warfare but the question
is do you want to do oh did I want to do
something right or just do something
easy yeah that's true because the the
fuel manual like any field manual like
when you want to go refer to it you
don't want to be searching around on
yeah okay what is that one part you know
that deals with this and boom you can
just go to this yeah track name in here
there so like I said if we could have
done the easy thing and and whatever you
know had everyone just being able to
click on it real easy
I apologize but if you want the right
way then that's what I had to do so
that's that book
and then national on front that's the
leadership consulting company that I
have with Lafe Aven but JP Danelle Dave
Burke if you want to have us come and
work with your business
contact info at a salon front comm and
if you have any questions or if you have
any answers or if you just want to
continue this conversation you can find
us on the interwebs on Twitter on
Instagram and on the face Bucky echo is
at echo Charles and I am at Xhaka will
Inc and finally thanks to everyone out
there for making this podcast possible
to those of you in the military
especially those right now on the
forward line of our own troops facing
evil every day thank you for providing
this freedom that we enjoy and to the
first responders in law enforcement and
Fire and EMS thank you for taking care
of us while we are here at home and the
rest of you that are out there that are
working and building and producing and
creating and leading keep leading keep
stepping up keep taking on challenges
and keep striving to do more and to be
more keep picking up the pace and keep
pushing harder and no matter what the
odds or what the probabilities keep
getting after it so until next time this
is echo and Jocko